Yes,
Ella,
what's up my friend?
What's up with you,
eleanor?
My long running friend,
one of my longest running friends in
Hollywood and a girl who's now a
professional,
legit professional standup comic who I
always knew for years as a waitress.
I always tell everybody this story,
but it's true.
Eleanor was my goto person to find out
someone who was a hack.
There would be someone would say,
Oh,
you've gotta check out this person.
They're amazing.
I go,
okay,
cool,
and then I go,
eleanor,
did you see a blah,
blah,
blah.
She's like fucking hack.
And there was a lot of people that got
tricked.
Trickery is big.
A lot of people who we thought were
like,
you think they're legit and you see him
a few times and you're like,
oh,
what's going on here?
Yeah,
there's a lot of that.
There was a lot of them I feel like,
and I used to tell my customers I'd be
like,
alright,
right here,
you're going to want to go to the
bathroom.
You want to stay in there for awhile.
While when you came to the store,
you were at the store before?
I was 93,
I came in [inaudible] 94,
so when I was there you were already
there,
but those were dark years.
There was not the beginning in the
beginning I was still doing three shows
in the alarm.
Was it like 97,
98?
It just kind of.
Yeah,
around then it got bad.
Yeah.
Well when we first got there,
Martin Lawrence was on top and he would
come there all the time and fill the
place.
Sort of like a Louis does now.
He comes and Joe Rogan x,
but no,
my first ex fiance used to represent
Martin Lawrence.
Oh,
that's right.
I have a complex fiances.
Not a closer guys.
Not yet,
but you were.
You were like,
you were like receiving like a master
class in comedy before he ever did it.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
like I would watch them all the time
because then when I wasn't at the store
I was with my fiance and we'd be at
comedy clubs.
We were on the road with Chris rock when
he was doing bringing the paint because
Chris was his other client,
so it was like watching everybody.
That's how I became friends with
sheriff,
uh,
through my first ex fiance,
so we would go to all,
he was booking the Riviera and then I
would help them book people once in a
blue moon.
And of course they all get panned
idiots.
Isn't it crazy that Jericho was booking
the Riviera?
We always knew him as the booking guy
who's really fun,
hang out with.
So just such a great guy.
And then all of a sudden he's on the
fucking greatest show all the time.
What it was so weird for me to watch him
on the soprano's.
I'm like,
how is this possible?
He's like,
I might get this part.
I'm like,
what?
Why?
We were all like freaking out,
like,
are you kidding?
And then he finally told me,
he goes,
I finished the paperwork today.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
I'm freaking out.
I couldn't wait to see him on the,
you know,
he has the best fucking spaghetti sauce
in the world.
I know.
I have to try it.
It's really good.
Studying.
What is it called?
Lookup Steve's Europe is sauce like
something in New York.
It's one on Sopranos.
Was he was a younger,
clean bobby,
bobby,
bobby.
Bobby,
yeah.
He,
he,
they made him put a gut suit on,
like they made him,
like,
he wasn't that big.
He's pretty big now.
Like if you wanted to do it now,
I probably wouldn't have.
Yeah,
he's good.
He's a fucking character thing.
Thank God for people like that.
There it is uncle Steve's.
That's what it is.
Control Steve's always something like
that.
And what is the,
is it uncle Steve's?
Steve's and y.com.
Uncle Steve's and [inaudible] dot com.
But he has amazing pasta sauce and that.
We've known this guy for forever.
Easily.
Like I feel like I've known him since
the day I got here.
Yeah.
I've known him forever and he's always
been awesome because he did,
he booked like big clients like that for
billy.
He introduced me to Lichtenburg my
business manager.
It's been my business manager forever.
He got the stamp of approval from EPA
guy.
He's a good guy.
He's a real guy.
But we,
you know,
we've,
we've had a chance to see a lot of,
uh,
like we,
we got a chance to see Richard Pryor
together.
Remember those students for a year.
I remember I was so nervous I was in
that office at the comedy store and I
brought them in water and I was like,
oh my God.
Because we used to get punished for
listening to his stuff.
So then I was like,
I told him that and he's like,
that's good.
And then later on his wife wouldn't let
me bring him the too nice.
He used to call him Martinis,
he'd bring me in Tunis,
Tunisia.
So I was like three to prowl,
bring them whenever he wants,
fast for cocaine,
I'm going to go find,
you know what I mean?
It's exciting.
So,
uh,
I brought it to him and she made me
change it to water.
He made me change it.
I love her.
I know what she was doing,
but at the same time it's like he's
sick,
let him have his Friggen Martini,
you know what I mean?
And I brought it on stage and he sipped
it and he knew it was water and he was
like,
bitch,
oh my God.
Richard Pryor doesn't like me.
No bitch wipe.
No.
But yeah,
I didn't want to get in trouble.
I didn't know if it was his meds that
would counteract.
You never know why she was doing it.
But.
No,
I hear Ya.
I mean ultimately you have to listen to
her.
She's like,
she can't remember.
So I did it.
Yeah,
he did it a long time.
I had to go on after him a lot.
Oh yeah,
for a year.
He did a year.
He did Monday,
Wednesday,
Friday.
And then it switched down to just
Wednesday.
Yeah.
I don't remember how many times I went
on after him,
but I remember I bombed basically every
single one of them,
like I might have got over a couple of
times.
It was packed.
It was just,
it was weird too because he was really
ill.
Chili carrier bought chewy.
And um,
who else?
James?
No,
it wasn't bad.
It was.
I don't think it was.
It was Maryland.
Martinez.
His husband remember?
Yeah.
David,
just to help him and Julie used to help
Richard Pryor get to the stage now.
I remember.
I'm afraid to put my headphones all the
way off.
I don't think I'm weird.
I don't know.
I have a paranoia and worry that
someone's going to sneak up on it.
I don't know what that.
You sort of blocked this filly.
That's that old school.
Philly philly has a UFC lightweight
champion of the world now from Philly
know that Alvarez.
Oh Wow.
He's from philly.
How come I didn't know that.
That stinks.
But uh,
that's awesome.
And how are the fights this weekend?
It's insane.
The opera is one was probably the most
insane.
Well I didn't watch of those was a big
underdog.
He felt hot.
Dos Anjos on the Internet.
It was on the Internet.
It was.
Oops was only on UFC fight reflex like a
cat on UFC fight pass.
And so I don't think a lot of people.
So I don't know how many people watched
the fight past ones,
but I don't think,
I know it's not as much as Fox.
I don't think it's as much as a paper
view,
but I could be wrong at this point
because I know there's millions of
millions of people would have fight pass
now I,
I don't,
I don't know that the actual numbers,
but fipass is awesome.
You can watch every fight that's ever
taken place and they have a few world
title fights on it now.
So that world title fight was a part of
the three day celebration.
So it was a heartfelt dos Anjos versus
Eddie Alvarez for the lightweight title
and then it was a,
you want to young Jay check and a logic
a day on Friday night for the women's
strawweight title.
And then there was the big UFC 200.
So it was three nights of insane fights
thing.
I think I came off stage when the girls
were fighting and I came,
I went to show my friend the bar at the
comedy store,
you know,
the bar,
and I was like,
oh,
come in here.
And everybody's like.
I was like,
oh,
I forgot we're doing comics.
Sorry guys,
I'm going to go out.
So.
But yeah,
it was crazy cool.
Seeing rock back and he killed it.
Dude.
Brock Lesnar beat a world.
Barack Obama like a world class
heavyweight.
How dare you.
I'm just asking a question guy.
Yeah.
He beat a world class heavyweight.
It's crazy.
Beat Mark Hunt mean he fucking
legitimately mark beat Mark Hunt.
He avoided getting knocked down on his
feet.
He took them down to fucking gorilla.
He took him down like nobody can you
watch him take,
wanted to take Mark Hunt down and you're
like,
Jesus,
who's stopping that?
How are you stopping that?
He just,
his horsepower is just so insane.
When he gets a hold of a judge,
it's just boom and he's taking them down
because Mark Hunt is a difficult guy to
take down and Mark Hunt is all of 265
pounds.
He's a big fucking guy.
So for brock to do that to him that way,
Jesus Christ,
he's,
I could probably tell you,
is that what a good example of somebody
that doesn't supposedly you steroids to
look,
that guy's a monster.
His muscles are crazy.
And supposedly he got tested,
right?
Yeah.
He got for this fight.
He got tested five times within a very
short period of time,
but let's just be completely honest in
the nature of a,
uh,
open discourse when you look at someone
and they're jacked as fucked,
it could easily be genetics because
there are girls that have giant tits for
no reason,
like size,
double e tits,
and you're like,
what the hell?
And they're 100 percent natural.
And then there's some girls that are
just,
they don't have very large boobs,
girls besides you.
There's a lot of people out there that
have this,
this thing going on,
this task or this is just a giant
difference between human shapes.
Right?
And so there are people that are built
like that.
My friend Sidley as a buddy of mine from
a back in Boston,
he was shocked and he didn't even lift
weights.
He's just Jamaican kid that I was
friends with.
Oh my God,
he was fucking,
he was ridiculously yoked and he barely,
he barely worked out.
I mean he did like a kickboxing things
and some pushups,
maybe not.
He was never lifting weights.
Like he was just doing martial arts
stuff and he was jacked.
My brother Charlie was like,
that.
Always muscly up until like two years
ago has changed.
Don't tell him I said that.
Oh,
I'll get pissed.
You hear that little kid to listen to a
podcast.
You know the little kid,
a little muscle kid.
That was super kid.
Have you seen him now?
He works at Universal Studios as in the
water world exhibit and now he's just
normal.
Normal.
Kind of has a beer gut now.
Like he stopped lifting because he said
it was boring man.
Well this wasn't a case of then they
alleged that his parents had had him on
steroids.
Probably staring.
That's awful.
It's really sad.
If that's the same store that I'm
thinking about,
I think there's been more than one of
those like little yoke dudes.
I know this is one little yoke dude that
had a genetic disorder that cows have
some times and those whippet dogs have
sometimes we had to.
Have you ever seen that?
The whip it dogs and get the double
muscle disorder?
No,
my dog was lazy,
but she was a little bit.
It's different.
Just assume if they have the extra
muscle,
they'd be more with,
oh,
there's this thing that happens to
whippets and some cows that's called.
It's called a myostatin inhibitor and a
milestone staten inhibitor.
Apparently it regulates the amount of
muscle tissue,
the carry around with you.
So when these whippets get it,
they look like the hulk.
They look fake.
They look like a movie.
See,
I've seen pictures of it.
Pull up a photo of a whippet mio staten
Tibbott her dog.
You know how to spell that.
But apparently there's a boy in Germany,
at least one kid that's confirm that was
born with this disorder.
So he's really young,
but he's jacked.
He's just fucking super yolked Baby
Jack.
This is what the men look at their
faith.
So like really weird.
They're usually a very slender dog.
Very kangaroo looking.
Yeah,
to kangaroo.
Scare the fuck out of me now.
It's like all the sudden they started
getting jacked up.
We're in.
When I was a kid,
when I was a kid.
Yeah,
they definitely live chat.
They looked like they were like fucking
school teachers,
like they were newspaper reporters or
something,
or like a librarian.
It didn't look like these yoke monsters.
You see the one that's knocking on the
window of the person's house like,
I want to come in.
Have you seen that video yet?
Man?
Knocking on the door.
Look at them.
Come on.
Look how big that thing is.
That's their big.
Yeah,
look at that.
They're like,
what in the what in the fuck is that?
That's fake.
No kidding.
I've seen it live.
So what the Hell's going on?
Do you think they have that extra muscle
thing like you said,
taking Dick Pills,
steroids and dick pill.
What a fucking bizarre animal that is.
That is amazing.
Bouncy mammo that will kick you and try
to hurt you.
Fuck you up.
No,
no,
no.
They're not always nice.
Feed them.
I fit.
I felt the big guys.
You got to be really careful around
that.
Real.
Is that a real post?
They say though,
they say though that if you find them in
the wild,
you are not supposed to ever approach.
While this was a beating off,
is that.
Can you repeat?
No,
no son we saw to having sex.
Oh,
the video though that it's kind of went
around last week is a kangaroo seeing
its reflection in somebody's window and
it's trying to fight it so.
But the guys on the other side with the
camera,
it's just as jacked.
Like kangaroo,
like punching the window.
Like it's scary.
Oh my gosh.
Video.
Yeah.
It's one of the coolest video that came
out last week.
If you just type in a kangaroo,
a window fist fighting himself in a
window,
shadowboxing a window.
That's a weird animal.
I love them.
I think they're great,
but it's so weird what it does though.
The way it acts that sits on its tail,
it's bouncing around these legs and then
it's got those jagged upper body.
They were.
There was like a.
They get spooked.
Easy to like this one big one was trying
to have sex.
I'm going to say it wasn't sex.
It was definitely rape,
but it was like he was pulling her back
and she was trying to get away,
but there was a reason she was trying to
get away because there was like a weird.
When come they want to kill him.
They all scattered.
Then they went under the tree and then
they got into it and I was like,
oh,
maybe she just wanted some privacy or.
That was really interesting how they had
to sneak out,
but she was scared and then as soon as
this weird thing came,
it was like a wind.
They all went scattered and then they
got back into.
It was exciting.
Kinga.
Yeah,
this is it.
This is so scary.
So knock on the door.
That one's not too jacked.
Boy.
It's creepy though.
Oh my God.
What's this?
And he starts getting pissed.
You scratched my window.
My window.
This is the right video or maybe a
mirror.
Oh my God.
He's throwing himself at the window.
Fuck man.
He's trying to themselves.
Oh,
he's trying to fight.
What he sees as a reflection in the
window at your house is a creepy animal.
Now they're beautiful.
But they don't eat meat.
Right?
Those are herbivores.
You got got me.
They let us feed them some weird shit.
What was it lacking is protein.
So it smelled terrible and it was a
little like look like little pills.
Pellet thinks.
Well,
you know,
gorillas don't eat meat.
Really?
Just grasses.
Yeah,
they're 100 percent vegetarian.
It's why they're so gentle.
Oh Wow.
Okay.
Here's the herbivores.
The grasses,
flowers,
leaves,
ferns,
Moss,
and even insects.
Interesting.
Like cows,
Kangaroos regurgitate their food and
read through it before it's ready to be
totally digested.
Juvenile kangaroo reviews the outside
world from the Pouch of adult female
right now.
They've seen Eddie,
if he got,
um,
he got fucking chased by one in
Australia.
He told the story of how he thought it
was fake because it was so big because
it was like a fucking seven foot
kangaroo.
He thought it was fake and he got out of
the car and he was with a bunch of
Australians and he starts walking
towards it and his friend go and his
friends stopped him and he said,
get back in the car and you know,
bad Australian accent.
Pretty Rad,
right?
So the dude ran back,
Eddie ran back to the car and apparently
this fucking kangaroo is going to go
after them.
Like this giant kangaroo is like,
if you go too close to them,
if they think you're a threatened,
they probably been fucked with people
unless they were in captivity.
Like where I went to see them chasing a
golf court after golfers on Jurassic
Park.
Never do that.
Here's my point to that thing.
Ate Meat.
We'd be Foxville.
Imagine if there was like a bunch of
them and they ate meat.
There were predators bouncing.
We'd kill them.
We'd have to kill them.
Right?
Don't have to kill.
I don't want to fight you.
Is that why they are like,
oh,
I feel like fighting tonight,
Jack Ufc Kenga roles.
Why don't they that they're just a
preference.
Like do they ever cross the line and go,
you know what,
I'm just going to eat this,
this bird right now because I'm hungry.
Maybe have to cross to them.
Well,
Kangaroos,
I dunno if they.
Birds with cows.
Do cows eat birds where they find them?
If they find them on the ground,
they eat nesting birds.
The birds a fall out in the fall on the
ground.
That dog had a debt burden.
His mouth when we're home a couple of
weeks ago.
That's normal though,
right?
With dogs like was a at these people's
house in Montana and they had this cat
and his fucking cat at a graveyard in
front of his house.
They bring their monsters.
This cat had brought in like two or
three birds dead birds.
Now.
This little tiny sparrows and shit
because there's two barnyard cats.
It just wandering around Jack and
things.
Are you a cat guy?
I love dogs too though.
I love.
Yeah,
that's right.
But I love them all.
I don't know if I could do cats too
sneaky.
They're just getting by.
See this as well.
This cows Keaton chases after them too.
Man.
It's not just simply that it aided by
accident because one of them were these
other birds or dive bombing on his head
on her head,
I should say it's girl and as they're
dive bombing on her head,
she's just slowly but surely like
chasing after this little bird that fell
on the ground.
Then she wants up jacking it in front of
it's,
you know,
health ones July that that's what they
do to me.
You know,
bowls only eat grass too and bowls like
a bowl.
Bowls are super fucking crazy
aggressive.
They think of that have put some shit on
the grass now.
They've always been crazy.
That's why people would ride bulls
because you have to be an asshole.
So I just some famous bull rider,
he or bold guy,
matthew door,
you can see the new things where they
put the,
the big balls around them and they run
around and let them,
right?
They.
No,
no,
no.
He's talking about something totally
different.
There's a new.
There's some thing that people are doing
now and have you seen it?
They get into like a ball.
You climb into a ball and you like
bouncing into each other and you could
sort of run and collide into each other.
That's awesome.
Have you done it?
No.
No,
no.
But they're doing it with bowls.
Okay.
That's a little stupid.
Crazy.
Can't they poke a hole in it?
No.
No I can't.
I guess they can.
They say they have like the kind of
horns that I've been poking part is
those rubber tips on the end of them.
You got to put like a little,
a little super ball tennis ball on it.
Fuck man.
No.
Because we have um,
what's that place with the trampolines
lyric?
See these people,
they get these balls on that to me,
seems that you're going to blow your
fucking acl out click.
You can still hit you in the Dick.
Oh my God.
It's covered.
These people are easy.
What is happening here?
Oh my God.
I can't believe they're going to do
this.
Okay.
So they're standing out here.
I got to see.
And they all have these balls on and
they just released the bowl and it's
just running around kicking.
This is more than one bowl.
Oh,
Jesus Collides and oh dude.
Oh my God.
You could get trampled.
Forget that.
This is crazy.
This is a terrible idea.
Look at that guy.
He's like,
oh my God.
He's running away.
Which is amazing.
Well,
he's lucky he's alive.
He's certainly lucky that he had gone
through the asshole.
That bull could easily like this for
what?
People listening.
This ball is small.
It's from the waist up.
His entire
legs are exposed.
They should've have had it,
so they're all.
You're in the ball completely.
Oh my God.
He got hit in the midsection.
This is terrible.
Oh my God.
This is.
It did deflated.
Oh,
for sure.
Got Deflated.
Says it got bent too,
and I think the guy's dead.
He's not moving your time to go see.
You got to wake up.
Soon as he took the.
He took the thing off.
He doesn't even have it on the bulls out
there like,
oh fuck.
Yeah.
I would play that game in that little
trampoline thing.
That's the only place to do it.
What the fuck is it that we love this,
like part of us,
like here,
honestly,
we're looking,
we're watching something fucking
ridiculous.
We're watching it from the point of
like,
we're like,
oh man,
this is crazy.
I can't believe they do this.
Like mid air.
Come on.
What is this like?
Why are we so attracted to this?
Okay.
It is weird that we're attracted to it,
but think of a guy mid air with his legs
spread Eagle and he's about to land on a
bull.
You know what I mean?
Like what's going through his head?
We're watching.
He's a little slower than we are.
He probably felt like if it's a thing,
it's okay.
I could do this.
People feel like if it's a thing,
you know what I'm saying?
Like if there's a thing that people do
and other people do it what it could do
it.
It's a thing.
You put the fucking.
He might be the first group.
He might be one of the first tasters.
Yeah.
What if they were like,
oh,
we're testing something out.
Can you come test this out for us?
Would you be our Guinea pig?
Did you do it?
Fuck that.
No,
I mean,
which is ironic because I hosted fear
factor,
but no,
I wouldn't.
I wouldn't want to have anything to do
with anything like that.
That's crazy.
It needs to be bigger and used to be
where you're inside the ball and it
needs to be like a stronger material and
then it'd be okay.
I think pretty strong material,
but here's.
There's bull horns coming out.
Here's the problem with that.
Here's how I see it.
People I think vastly overestimate their
ability to move their body vastly and
they think when that ball's going,
I'll just fucking go with it and I'll
just fucking,
you know,
we still going to be looking at fake
them out backfield.
That bull comes on you so fast.
Yeah.
It's a bad quote right there.
Got excited.
I don't know that anybody else thinking
I'm going to get into this fight.
When you see that bull launch,
that dude into the air,
you can.
I guarantee you that guy at that moment
when he was flying was like,
oh no,
I fucked up.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
This is not what I felt like.
This is.
Wait,
this was not in the brochure.
You can't control.
You can't control this guy.
That guy probably didn't think before or
after or during these rides is a dumb
ass.
He's probably one of those.
I don't give a fuck dude.
Hey Man.
I'm crazy.
I to tell you what I'll do.
I'll climate side of that phone with
that bolt hit me.
I don't give a fuck.
You could shoot an apple off my head.
Dude.
I'm scared to die.
If my granddad was an Indian hundred
percent Apache broke,
I got that warrior blood.
I don't give a fuck what I gotta do what
I gotTa do.
Shit.
I'll be the first in line first in the
lab.
You see the brain's slipping out of
their skull.
Bad knees fucked up.
Farmers back.
I don't give a fuck.
It's in there.
There's a lot of those dudes.
Fear factor thing.
I would do it just for the money.
I would only do the stunts.
I couldn't do the food.
I mean I can barely a regular
restaurant.
You could have got lucky.
Some people got there.
Was it was no parody like as far as like
how difficult things were on some shows?
There were.
I mean it was always totally random
what,
what you got what you had to eat.
But some of it was easy.
Like roaches are easy.
No,
no.
I'm telling you,
roaches,
d,
they don't.
They barely tastes like anything.
We ate those like,
you know what I mean?
Like so picky.
It was a joke in there somewhere,
you know,
comes on you.
And Boom,
here we are full circle.
I'm telling you,
but it's all in your head because if you
eat crabs,
you're eating the same thing.
They're like a crab.
Oh,
you want me to see for the worst fear
factor to me is like a Swedish fish.
If you really needed the money and you
were there,
I looked at the other people you're with
and you're like,
I'm not going to let these pussies beat
me crazy.
Yeah.
I'm a little competitive but not.
I don't know if I could beat that
competitive,
like letting everybody see me,
shit my pants right.
That.
Because that would probably go right
through me.
That's what I'm afraid of,
like I would throw up or something
awful.
Do you think you have an allergy to
weird foods or is it just you're just
thinking.
I'm just a little retarded.
I know not to say that word.
Sorry to hear.
This is a retard free zone on facebook
that people do that people are angry.
It's just go outside.
Consumer sent me a list of words to say
other than that,
how crazy is that?
So whatever the language police,
they're out there and they kind of pull
you over and give you a ticket and they
feel really good about it.
I don't like what you're saying.
I don't like how you're saying it.
Intent is not as critical as the actual
words that come out of your mouth to add
the language.
Police,
I will punch in the face that you hit
them.
Physical language police,
not a regular police.
I don't do that.
I'm not crazy.
I'm just.
I'm not.
I'm pro everybody.
I think everybody should learn to
behave,
but if a language that they're
misbehaving to me,
the language police
so they get punched in the face.
Maybe I am a little violent.
I apologize.
That's the punch.
I do love to punch.
Isn't that terrible?
Punching people.
You're.
You're like one of those walk by the
punch people in the alarm.
In my house.
It's an insane asylum.
If there was 10 of us in a row home.
So I have six brothers.
I woke up every day to a punch in the
face,
you know,
other stuff,
whatever you dick to the failure of
tolerance.
You grew up with like a lot of tolerance
for bullshit.
So your patient,
you're thin,
you know,
I mean your skin gets.
Then I can't have thick thicker if you
have like I have one niece that was a
little thin skinned and then my brothers
just beat that out of her poor thing.
She didn't know what she was getting
into.
We were like,
oh,
are you sensitive?
Come over here for a second.
And then now she's cool now.
Now she's like,
oh,
I get it.
But it's stupid to be sensitive.
Well,
how much could your parents have control
you think?
So many of you.
Especially because my parents split up
so.
So when I was like eight,
they split up,
so it was like,
oh shit,
it's on now.
Like they can't catch me now.
But that wasn't true because my dad's a
marine and he only moved like five
blocks away,
so any new,
every cop in the neighborhood.
So if I,
if I did anything he knew the next day
or he'd see me,
he'd be out and see me and I'd be like,
Oh shit.
But I was afraid of my dad,
like,
are you guys,
I'm still afraid of my dad.
He's 80 every once in a while be like,
Hey dad,
you,
you know,
you shouldn't do that,
but I still backed.
Well he's crazy.
But even today you couldn't get upset at
him and talk to them.
Like personal,
personal.
No,
I had a fight with.
I talked to him.
I,
I call them because I use them for
material and you know,
he just gives gems,
you know what I mean?
Like now he lives in Rehobeth beach
cheats.
Retires,
it's in Delaware and it's um,
it's a predominantly gay area.
My Dad's a marine,
like covered in tattoos.
He still wears his dog tags because they
like to jerk off to.
Yes,
he did not know that.
Now he knows that and he also had.
He refers to lesbians.
It's girl faggots.
I'm like,
that's not what they are,
and then I'm like,
they're lesbians and he's like,
I don't care what were there from the
UFC has an openly gay women's
bantamweight champion.
Oh my God.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
she's a beast to.
I would say at the UFC.
One thing I love about him is that the
women are just as good.
Amanda Nunez,
she's the new champ.
She knocked out of me.
She stopped doing the first round was
free.
I only saw the highlights,
but great fight.
She's awesome.
She's so fast.
She's like lightening fast.
Her hands are so explosive.
Like she's.
She's so hard to get to.
He,
she's one of those girls that she's like
a sprinter and like in the third and
fourth and fifth round,
that's when she's going to have a hard
time because he blows out so much.
But see,
she takes people out like she's very
good.
Like from standing and on the ground as
well or Jujitsu is really good,
but she's so explosive.
The only worry or concern that people
have is that I wonder if she can sustain
that level,
but to fight like that.
Anybody.
She's incredible,
but it's really,
it's really interesting because she has
had fights where she kind of faded in
the past,
but,
but you've got to get through that storm
that she brings and it's just so she's
so explosive.
Like I,
it's between her and I mean there's,
I don't think anybody moves quite as
fast as her or our hits quite as hard as
her in that division.
Like there might be girls like Holly
Holm that might be like a little bit
more skillful as a strike or a much more
experienced than the striker.
The very few people hit with the kind of
pop that she's got something at watch.
Holly Holm was great.
She's awesome watching her it from the
get like I wish they had that when I was
a kid.
I think we talked about that before.
Like I definitely would have gotten into
as kit.
I know you would have easily because I
wouldn't have gotten arrested as much,
so it's like easier that way if there's
another woman's been away that doesn't
get enough credit.
Raquel Pennington.
Oh,
you've seen her.
She's good now.
I'm not trying to scam me.
Stop me face.
I'm like,
oh.
I thought that ferocious.
So very,
very skillful.
She's like on the outside of the very
top.
She but she's a.
she's beaten some really tough people.
I watch and I get jealous.
I think I want to get into her.
Holly Holm and her fought Holly Holm,
UFC debut and it was a split decision.
Really close fight.
She's.
She's very good and better now than.
Excuse me.
Better now than she was then and that
she wears a shirt that says rocky
killers just told me this.
She's got this one submission victory
where she catches this girl Ashley Evan
Smith and a bulldog choke and chokes her
unconscious with like one second to go
in the first round.
Let's go over her neck and she's out
cold in this puddle of blood was.
It was one of those where you're doing
commentary like wow.
It was a screamer,
so ridiculous.
But um,
women's Bantam weight division is filled
with fucking killers now.
There's so many good fighters.
It's like they're,
they're trading titles.
The main events.
Which title I,
that's a big,
big deal.
Women's sports,
you know,
they don't.
What's definitely a big deal for the
biggest paper.
Have you ever.
I mean obviously it wasn't going to be
of John Jones didn't test positive for
something,
but because he did,
it's.
Yeah.
So is he admitted to it yet?
Is he saying what he did?
No,
he's not.
He's not saying anything.
Tailpiece son and leaked the information
during my last podcast,
so it's out of it's shell has leaked out
information.
It could be.
Is that what he said to me out there?
I had no,
nothing.
I didn't hear anything about.
Honestly,
I'm in a weird position because I don't
think you're supposed to.
I don't think he supposed to.
Anybody is supposed to be talking about
the medical results until like it gets
released.
I don't know how it works.
I really don't.
I'm going to plead ignorance,
right?
I'll plead ignorance all day.
Bridal name.
I think he probably took boner pills
because they have all that shit in them,
you know,
like they have potent pills,
have steroids in them.
Boner pills,
because I just found Joe's gas station
over here.
It has like the best.
I've never seen these right on is known
for his love of the boner pill.
He makes what you would call a boner
pill contour.
He's actually read blogs about boner
pills and directed me to reviews of
boner pills.
Terrifying.
But I mean,
these things have steroids in them.
They have a bunch of stuff and if you
party wasn't the last thing he got
busted for cocaine or something.
If you bus,
if you do cocaine,
a lot of guys take these because you can
get hard off of having cocaine.
And so if he takes boner pills,
then he's.
Gonna is a little too much speculation
for respect.
And uh,
I'm going to have to step out of this
conversation.
Neither confirm nor deny.
Take turns into a werewolf.
Starts chasing us around the rope.
It just lays his dick out on the domain.
Oh my God.
What would happen?
I don't need,
this one has a Hologram of a rhino and
he turned it.
It turns into a but at one is
interesting.
Now I'm at the gas station.
How do you know?
What are the good ones and one of the
bad ones?
How do you know what to take?
I've come to the conclusion that if it
has a rhinoceros,
it works in.
The great thing if you're,
if you're lucky,
lived in New York City,
New York City has these bodegas
everywhere.
They all have them and they have older
product which is usually stronger
because people died from them or like
you're going to have a giant heart on
caught,
but okay,
we keep talking about this,
but we need to fucking run a test here
and find out what.
What are you going to take it?
But what I'm thinking about doing is
taking it to a laboratory.
Oh,
there you find out what's in it,
but I don't want the fucking Chinese
triad to be asking me like some shitty
Mickey rourke not.
It shouldn't even say shit.
Look good.
One Year of the Dragon.
That was a great movie.
Just trying to,
I was going for comic effect.
I had to check myself a reality,
but I just.
I mean I don't.
I'm listening.
I'm Pro Rhino,
right?
You want to solve these things.
They work,
they're great.
Just don't take it.
The black cat ones or any of the cat
ones because those ones actually made me
see visually and stuff and I think it's
like blood pressure or something.
Maybe it's all fucked up,
so don't take those because that fucks
with your blood pressure.
Pretty hardcore.
Yeah.
Don't,
don't take risks.
If he tells you don't take it.
Don't take it folks.
Trust me.
I don't care what you think your
tolerance is.
Eli,
if you think you have the same tolerance
is red band.
You're incorrect.
Yeah,
he's got you.
What do they get you high like they make
it kind of rage.
They were the ones that have the
steroids
in them,
which I've found.
I think most of them have steroids and
you can tell the difference which those
because you immediately want to fuck
you.
You're not only getting hard.
You're like,
I need to get laid right now.
Will you start with molly?
I know you directed me to a website,
FDA dot Gov,
but one of them that was explaining all
the different ingredients that were in
these things that a guy broke it down
and what they do to you.
Oh yeah,
there's a few.
There's a few of those,
but unfortunately that guy doesn't.
He's only talking about what's on the
back.
Like what they're saying that's in it.
Oh,
testing tested it.
Let's see if anybody's ever actually
tested what is in boner pills.
They,
they,
they fda tells you everything that's on
all of them.
You could even look up rhino and you see
some older ones on there and they're
usually steroids and it's usually Viagra
generic.
Oh,
okay.
So the FDA has a list of what they
called them.
Write the names,
but what's to stop you from just
starting to sell something called Rhino
10 like this is rhino seven like you
don't have.
I bet they don't own rhino.
The same company actually has like the
Rhino,
a brand one that you're holding right
now as I,
I've got all the way up to [inaudible]
69 and I've had about 20 different
rhinos,
so they just changed the,
the number.
Every time they get in trouble too.
A different one.
Look at this public notification.
My steel woody to contains,
contains hidden drug ingredient.
The Food and Drug Administration is
advising consumers not to purchase or
use my steel,
woody a product promoted and sold for
sexual enhancement on various websites
including blah,
blah,
blah.
And possibly some retail stores.
FDI laboratory analysis confirmed that
my steel woody contains select solidify.
Oh,
that's,
um,
that's Viagra.
Yeah.
Okay.
It says it's the,
how do you say that word?
A den of Phil Identify Sildenafil.
Is that it says active ingredient in
Viagara.
So the main ingredient in used to treat
erectile dysfunction,
the undeclared ingredient may interact
with nitrates.
Found at some prescription drugs such
as.
Well.
Yeah.
So that's like for people who have heart
issues,
when they take like a blood pressure
medication,
if they're taking Viagra at the same
time,
they could fucking Croak.
Or if you have diabetes you don't take,
don't take it because these things will
fuck you up.
So these mice deal will you guys.
So if you don't cry fuckers.
Oh my God,
hold on,
scroll all the way up.
Go back to the top.
Hold on a second.
If the public notifications of how many
drugs contained or how many of these
supplements contain drugs.
This is insane.
So public notification ran a seven.
Hold on a second.
Extra contains hidden drug ingredients.
Neil phase,
natural sex enhancer contains a hidden
dreading group.
There's like a list over and over and
over and over.
And there's so many of them.
Rhino seven renaissance.
Scroll back up rhino seven right now.
Seven blue,
9,000.
Look,
there's dryness.
Seven blue,
9,000 is.
I don't know,
they just changed the number
one.
What's the new name?
Jon Jones has a headache.
They don't believe you
Jones.
If he did take these,
if he could sue rhino say bullshit.
I got a headache from it.
You say no head,
right?
That's true.
I mean the word is bond.
Millions of dollars.
If it's written on the front of the
pack,
there's a word is bond that holds true.
This is.
Wow.
I don't know.
Who knows this
crazy?
I can't.
I just don't understand.
If someone was going to take something
like that,
why wouldn't you take.
Well,
why don't you just take Viagra.
If you knew what's in Viagara,
like if you're going to get Viagara you
get a prescription for that.
I'll tell you what man.
I mean you can get it on the street,
but you can get anything on the street,
but I mean
it shows now a lot of guys giving me
Viagra that's like,
Hey Brian,
instead of giving me,
we'd.
They'll just give me a biography,
but I try it now.
It's not even close.
Not even close to that.
It's not even close to them
like this.
This little store bought the rhino seven
way better than a Viagra or any of the
car.
So it's what you think is probably like
steroids and maybe like amphetamines or
something.
He'd swole,
it swells up,
which he sold his Dick.
Like one of them.
I'm like,
wow,
I could sell it.
The uncle Steve,
will you take one of these?
We take one of these home and take one
and that doesn't seem like a good idea.
I just,
I don't know what the fuck is in those
things dude.
I'm not into taking some mystery drug
from.
You just saw the list of everything that
made that shit on an island somewhere in
the South Pacific.
They have slaves.
We push those out.
I mean,
who knows what the difference is?
Batch to batch.
There's no quality control like this is
the wild west shit in your body.
You are you really good at like
everything you put in your body,
you know what it is and what goes in as
much as you can,
but if you eat at restaurants you don't
really know.
You're right.
I'm the worst.
I'm.
Do you eat everything?
No.
Don't need for anything,
but I eat shitty food.
I mean like eat whatever you want to
say.
Everything I know you don't eat seafood
at all,
right?
Yeah.
No,
I don't like seafood,
but you eat like a monster or a great
metabolism.
You've always had a crazy metabolism,
but I like candy.
Like I'd eat Swedish fish and think,
oh,
I had fish for dinner and what I mean
like I love candy,
stuff like that.
Cake cookies while I'm at it took a
boner pill.
You feel uncomfortable?
No.
One of those.
I wonder.
That's what we should put on there.
I'll tell you what happens next and they
give me shit.
Wait a minute.
That came out wrong.
So somebody gave me a Viagra or cialis
was the blue one.
I think that's a Viagra and I didn't
know when to take it,
so I put it in my Zantex container.
Zantac is for heartburn,
Xanax,
Zantac,
Zantac.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
no,
I don't want to fly with this pill in my
pockets.
I'm just putting my Zantac for God.
I did that.
My girlfriend took it by mistake
thinking Zantac and she said that she.
She did.
She felt weird,
like I like felt tingly and stuff like
that,
but it didn't do anything but it looks
like Zantac.
Imagine if she went to work and got
popped for steroids,
you know,
if she had a job at ups or something
like that,
and navigate your urine sample,
well this is.
You're wasting your time here.
I didn't even smoke pot.
Your pants were swelling up.
Whoa.
They get it back.
Your employees on fucking hardcore
steroids pitches tweak and terrible.
Had a horse's foot.
I mean it was just.
She said,
she said it was kind of tingly,
not a moose knuckle but a horse's foot.
It was gone.
Like this.
Moose knuckle is a weird.
That's a good one.
That is a fun thing to say.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like if you don't,
if you don't think that Moose knuckle is
funny,
it's because you're avoiding humor.
I agree.
You're avoiding opportunities to learn.
Not a good person at heart.
He really aren't.
You should check yourself all the way
through at all the animals.
Portland,
Moose.
I mean,
how many people actually see a moose
knuckle?
Know what that looks like.
We had to have photos before it became a
moose knuckle because it's not like
that.
Many people see a moose.
That's a total loser.
That is a guy only on paper.
On paper.
You're right.
But think about it like before
traveling,
like I bet they would never call it
moose knuckle in the 18 hundreds because
they didn't have any pictures.
They had to see a moose.
Moose.
Women weren't allowed to wear pants that
too,
but like for the longest time.
So that's like an expression that we can
prove like did not exist before the.
Because if you lived in New York in like
1830 and you said,
oh,
so your moose knuckle.
They'd be like,
what the fuck does a Moose knuckle look
like?
I don't even know what.
They don't have a photo.
Where would they look at a drawing with
them and what they used to call it,
like a slave foot or maybe you loose
walking around because they weren't made
up back then,
but I don't think there were that many
that you would see them.
If you live in a city like New York City
lived in Maine,
you're like,
Oh,
you're just walking through my
neighborhood.
How many Moose though?
See it's not native to that much.
It doesn't have a large range in North
America.
It's got like the northern states.
Colorado,
Maine has moose,
New Hampshire.
I remember seeing a sign watch out for
the boost because they walk at their
real tall.
He hit your car.
Could hit him or something.
I was terrified.
It was the creepiest longest drive I've
ever did.
They're scary because you die when you
hit one of those.
Those those things kill people.
But then dear to deer deer kill 200
people a year in car accidents in just
the United States.
There was a ton I saw in Jersey a couple
of weeks ago.
I didn't.
I didn't see deer.
I just saw the signs,
but there was more than I've ever seen.
Yeah,
they're everywhere.
Everybody was talking about deers and
I'm like,
what?
And people looked.
It's because our predators.
You've gotten rid of all the predators.
Oh yeah.
Well let's just let some fucking hyenas
and mountain lions,
Louis take out all the back pain is a
mountain lions around your kids.
You fucking whack people are crazy.
I mean,
I,
I love crazy,
but at the same time they.
They're going a little too far with the
crazy these days.
Don't you think like as a comedian like
you are.
We need them.
You know?
I mean,
it's funny.
It's fun sometimes because it's
something to push back against.
Yeah.
Because some of them are just so
ridiculous,
so regressive.
Trying to control people you want,
you don't.
You're not like open like an open and
tolerant person.
As someone who wants to communicate the
difference between their ideas and your
ideas.
That's not what's going on.
Like joke about my dad,
he's the most UN-PC person there is.
I mean,
I know there's a lot,
but he's at the top.
I think bad guys from that generation.
My nieces and nephews,
the young ones that yell at him pop up.
He can't talk like that,
you know,
pop up.
You can't say that pump that hell is
this kid talking,
you know,
my,
my dad has weapons everywhere.
People are like,
oh my God,
like gun violence.
I literally went home.
I was working on the east coast,
right,
and I went to a funeral.
My,
my dad's brother,
my uncle Tom,
his girlfriend died 88 years old.
He's still what I'm saying.
It's taken rhino pills obviously.
So she,
uh,
whatever.
So there was a funeral and then we went
to his house and he's this tough,
tough man.
Like a real,
like he built bridges.
That's what he did with his life,
you know,
he was a marine for years and he stood
up to like look out the window and his
belt buckle with dangling and it said
Nra.
And I forgot where I was from for a
minute.
Like I,
these are the people that I grew up
around,
like I didn't,
it never phased me,
but we were always taught like,
you know,
you don't touch that,
you don't do this.
But my dad had grenades in the
typewriter stores.
I don't know what we need these for dad,
but somebody are you seeing things that
were happening in here?
But he was like that.
Me and my brothers,
of course we would get into that
description is my dad had grenades at
his typewriter store madness first of
all.
And they do what a typewriter stores.
Will you watch any guy,
ladies,
please do me a favor.
If you go over to his house and he says
that he's a poet and these kinds of
typewriter run,
just get out of there.
Run or call me.
I can fix the typewriter.
Especially if it's one of those old
school you typewriters.
If that guy writes all this stuff in an
old school that's called manual,
please don't fuck that guy.
Girls just making change.
I called my dad three days ago and I
said,
what are you doing?
He said,
fix it a typewriter.
I go,
will you please stop this?
Like I thought he was kidding,
but here are the neighbors still types
letters out.
And my dad,
if something broke and my dad had a
clean it up for him and he goes on.
I had a recent poll,
the ribbon,
and then I started having flashbacks.
I'm like,
why do I know how to read Spool Ribbon?
Why wasn't I educated properly in line?
You know what I mean?
Like that's it.
All I know is typewriters.
I could fix your typewriter.
I could do everything is crazy to me.
That laptop,
I don't know what that is.
And when you had to erase something you
had like the little white thing that we
used to sell though nine paint over it
and then you back up.
Yeah,
go always back.
Mess it up.
My Dad types with one finger.
I would have never learned how to type
if it wasn't for video games.
I learned how I learned how to type 100
percent so I could talk to people
quicker.
That's a good angle.
Playing quake.
That's how I learned how to type 100
percent.
That's a good angle for people like well
you don't need typing now,
but.
And we had typing in high school because
especially women,
they're like,
yeah,
learn to type.
You're not going to do anything else.
I used to write all my stuff out long
hand until I started playing video games
and when I started video games also want
to start writing blogs.
I didn't because I started like working
on figuring out how to type and I got
one of those Mavis Bacon things you ever
do that?
It's like a game,
it's got into video games.
I don't want them,
but maybe,
maybe it's Mavis beacon teaches typing.
Oh,
I see.
So it's a typing program but it's a
video game.
It and I grew up in a typo.
It's probably only for videos tutors,
but it's awesome.
It's like really a great way to learn
because the things show up and you're
supposed to keep your hands in the
position.
The perfect position.
Yeah.
And then when the little things are
moving across,
it's like you,
you have to try to keep up with what's
being typed in.
You have to follow it underneath it and
there's like games you play and I feel
like I sound like a spokesperson.
That's how I learned to type.
I learned to type you in that.
Can you do it without looking like are
you that good?
Oh yeah.
My mom's that person,
but I don't do it totally correct.
Um,
you know,
I've probably had a hurt finger when I
learned,
so I lift up one of them or something or
use like four on one side and $3.
Yeah,
there's definitely like an odd duck.
I remember they used to yell like in
typing class,
like,
do you use your pinkies,
these pitches,
pitches and not cooperative.
They don't work the way you think.
No,
don't worry.
It's not going to use the other finger.
My pinkies are so uncooperative,
like little toes.
But these fingers like I got it.
I got it.
Just give it a base to it,
but you don't know what the fuck are you
doing?
Come on,
come on,
come on.
Come on to my pinkies liquor beach.
Where been such news.
We'll look at the difference.
I did.
Fuck du Du,
Du,
Du.
You
fuck you get to shit.
Come on for everybody.
That's one of the strong man.
It's all about your mind,
Bro.
Mentality.
It's all about your mentality.
The mentality is no good.
I saw this dude once he was on um,
wasn't though.
Was it not sally Jessy Raphael,
one of those fucking shows.
It might've been Jenny Jones.
I don't remember what show it was.
Old School.
Right.
But I'll never forget this dude because
there's this girl and she was like,
dressing really trashy and she's like
disrespect and her mom has all this
crazy shit going on and this dude gets
up in the audience,
gets up in the audience and you know,
do you have any,
anything you want to say to her?
You know,
they'd go to the audience people's
responses.
He goes,
if you had a good personality,
you could pull that off if you had some
jazz.
He goes,
but you'll,
you'll personality sucks and that make
you look nasty.
I never forget that dude.
Your personality sucks and that make you
look nasty and everybody.
And everybody was like,
Oh shit.
It was me and candy Alexander will.
We're on newsradio together in between
takes and we're hanging out one of the
break rooms or whatever it was.
We were watching one of those daytime
shows.
This pre-internet man,
I'm just no Internet back then.
And that was like the perfect.
They look for now on the Internet as
well.
We use the internet existed,
but you go to like aol.com or something
like that.
You never saw anything like that?
No.
Yeah.
How long do you think it's been since
that all that's been coming up?
Like what's.
I feel like I have no idea of the
timeframe of when this became the thing.
It's kind of snuck up on us,
right?
It keeps getting more and more embedded
in everybody's alive.
Ari Shaffir and big Jay Oakerson did a
fucking hilarious podcast where Ari and
big J or on a roof in New York City and
their timing on this girl and this guy
and this girl are.
Yeah,
and this girl and this guy,
they keep about to get it on and they
check their phones.
They're on top of each other,
checking their phones on each other like
she's riding him and she's checking her
phone and he pauses in like grabbing her
ass.
He pauses and grabs his fault.
That doesn't make.
Might be pokemon go.
Doesn't mean I want to talk to you about
Pokemon Pokemon,
but I put it does.
It does make sense?
Do that.
People are crazy.
They're sucked into phones.
Phones draw you in.
Where are they looking for sexual
positions?
Oh No,
no,
no.
They're checking their text messages.
Bullshit ass guaranteed.
Some people just can't help it or get
into the message.
What's my message?
We'll look.
Got another message over.
Yes.
They were about to have trump other
things.
Some people are crazy.
There are people that are flat out 100
percent attached to that phone.
This is step one.
Eleanor.
APP addicts.
They didn't stop.
This is different.
This is different than the phone thing
is different because if you wanted to
say that you wanted to say that phones
are a drug and addiction,
right?
If you wanted to,
you'd have to sort out the consequences.
Like what are the consequences of this
drug?
We don't know about that.
I mean the consequences of coffee are
pretty mundane.
It's no big deal.
You know,
you get,
you get fired up.
This might be the most addictive drug
ever.
Like if it was a drug,
if it wasn't an object,
like what?
What is,
what drug do you walk down the street
and you see everyone on every one
holding their phone,
looking at their phone.
When you're looking down street,
you might see 40,
50 percent of the people holding a
phone.
Yeah,
I mean that is obviously it's a device,
but let's just classify it as an
obsession or as something that you're a
fixation.
Perhaps something that is just
overwhelmingly influential in the fact
that you pay so much attention to it in
your life.
This is more of a lover than anyone
you've ever known,
but if this fucking thing is with you
while you shit with you all the
companions,
but it doesn't trump sex like I'm sorry.
After you can't try this girl trying to
get some good.
Maybe I don't know what's going to
happen.
Were you already feeling towards me
looking at her for so long that you have
pathways carved in your anatomy?
Know Him with the ceiling Pokemon,
the pokemon games.
Taking it to the next level because when
I explain it,
explain what's going on.
The easiest way to say web pokemon is it
takes Google maps.
You have to sign into Google.
It takes Google maps and all the
information that's in Google maps and it
makes it the level of video game.
So instead of playing a level,
you're playing your own street,
you're finding you're finding creatures
in your house.
And uh,
so yeah.
So then there's places like churches are
called Jim's.
That's where you go and if you go to a
church you can train your fighter to be
stronger and stuff like that.
So you're using real world places and
like,
like landmarks and you're finding things
that like water fountains.
Like if you go to the water fountain,
there's a bunch of coins there.
So it's using the.
And what's crazy is like if you're at
the comedy store it on Google maps,
you can upload your own photos,
you know,
like,
like I was at the comedy store on Google
maps,
so it pulls that information also.
So if you're playing the game you'll be
like,
oh,
there's Andy Kaufman sign.
If we go to the Andy Kaufman sign,
we can get some treasures and it shows
you the Andy Kaufman signed in the video
game.
But here's the crazy thing,
in one,
like two days it's almost every single
person has downloaded and played it and
the crazy thing I was thinking of is how
awesome is it that it's connected to
Google and we're sending,
because it opens your camera at parts of
the game when you're battling and it's
scanning your room,
your houses,
and it's sending it to google.
So this is like the best way that Google
is now getting a complete map of our
house inside.
It's like it's scanning every street in
like one year.
Your Google is going to be able to see
every single inch of it every single
place inside and outside because of this
game.
How long has it been out?
Like three days.
Three days already.
I'm more phones on android than tinder.
And it's about to pass up twitter.
Yeah.
I really think we should bring
typewriters back.
I'm sorry.
And no one's thinking about this though.
We're just opening our camera and
recording our rooms and sending it to
google.
Wait a minute.
This real gentle yoga poses looking up
us.
I knew we were going to talk about us.
I pulled up some stuff already,
there's like a,
the interesting thing that's happening
with it being on open gps maps as those
places,
those locations,
like there's a guy's home that's been
turned into one of these gyms and he's
like mad that people are showing up
outside of his place because he bought
an old church and so churches in the
game automatically become Jim.
So people are hanging outside of this
house now.
But also interesting things like this
has happened where the West Westboro,
Westboro Baptist Church has been
overtaken by a gay friendly pokemon.
So people were like kind of,
I don't know necessarily trolling them
and whatnot,
but then,
uh,
so by walking around and looking for
things,
a teenager found dead body somewhere and
just three days they've already been
dead body found by teenager hunting
water.
Pokemon.
Yeah.
She found it underneath the bridge.
Oh my God.
This last part I was trying to get a
water.
Pokemon wiggins told CNN instead,
she made the alarming and alarming
discovery,
a dead body close to the Wyoming
highway.
Seven 89 bridge,
I'd probably would have never went down
there if it weren't for this game.
She admitted,
but the scary incident isn't deterring.
Her wigans says she will continue to
play the game.
I saw somebody playing on the highway on
the way here.
I saw somebody playing on the highway
last plastics bad enough we don't need
the last night when I was waiting for my
uber at my house,
I just three minutes I saw two different
groups of kids,
like one on skateboards and one on
bikes.
Just playing the game.
And what's scary is like on that article
now armed robbers are robbing people at
certain places in the game because they
know the kids are going to be there with
like new phones like I phones and stuff.
So they're waiting at certain places
coming out,
stealing our phones and because it
allows players to drop a lower module
and a real world location to attract
high numbers of Pokemon for 30 minutes.
The lure modules have reportedly also
been used by business owners to bring
people to their stores.
What?
Yeah.
So,
so this is the next level?
Yes.
This is,
this is what starts the next level,
this kind of thing though.
The next level of what's that Internet,
augmented reality that it's going to
take over and it's also scanning.
Just like snapchat scanned all our faces
using all these filters now and they
have perfect.
They could three d model.
All our faces now,
because we we've been scanning are faced
with now they.
They're scanning the whole entire United
States.
They're going to have maps of everything
inside and outside in like less than a
year.
Didn't.
We think though that eventually that
that was going to be inevitable and that
was going to be unavoidable.
There's the technology's gonna dissolve
all the windows.
Well this is the next is dissolving in
the windows.
That's also fascinating that it's an
augmented reality like that's what got
everybody in life,
that the augmented reality is what snuck
everybody in and then everybody's like,
Oh man,
let's play a game.
I'm part of the game.
Then you're completely sucked into this
very bizarre new world where you're
playing a game but wrapped around your
own actual environment.
What do you.
This guy owns the gym of that guy's
house,
so virtual owner of properly
technically,
and it can be stolen or taken there.
Woohoo.
I met the owner of my gym.
Nice guy.
Oh my God.
Was like,
uh,
yeah,
please don't tell anybody where I live,
dude.
Get away from my apartment.
They're going to get sued.
Those pokemon people are going to get
sued.
Sure.
There's going to be a lot of lawsuits
about this game.
There's gonna be a lot of people dying.
Like I said,
on the way here,
I saw somebody using it while driving
because that dead body with somebody
trying to get a water pokemon.
It was probably somebody murdered or a
homeless person?
Yeah,
didn't.
He could have been under that.
Where's the water?
Up with somebody.
Okay.
When you find something,
find like a water law.
Is that what it was?
No,
no.
It's an alert.
It's this thing that you can drop on the
ground and so did someone drop it where
the home was,
where the dead person was?
No,
she was just searching for pokemon go.
It's kind of.
It reminds me of like when you're a kid,
you know,
bicycle,
inner going around your neighborhood,
like playing adventure,
like looking at things and finding
things.
It's Kinda like that,
that makes you kind of go out in your
neighborhood and look at stuff like I
didn't know that there was like a buddha
across the street and like this forest
by my house and I found out by this game
because it was like go here,
you know,
there's some stuff here and so it's kind
of cool because it shows you around your
neighborhood and stuff like that that
you might've not known.
It's kind of like that old game,
a geo tagging game that people used to
play where it's like go to these
coordinates and you'll find like a
president and you know,
to got really cynical go.
You'd be like some sort of an alien
talking to you going move around your
coordinates and take photographs of
everything so perfectly.
Yeah.
It's really interesting to see what
businesses or businesses are doing.
Like dairy queen,
like I said,
dropped something on the ground is like
paying customers only can come here and
get pokemon.
So that's probably smart.
Yeah,
that's smart for them.
Can you imagine?
Like I,
I grew up in south philly.
We didn't look at anything and if we saw
something we just kept walking to do
that anymore.
Eleanor is no more slaves and you don't
have to ride a horse around taking
pictures around my mom's neighborhood.
Yeah.
All right.
So let me explain to me,
because let me understand how this
works.
You're,
you're playing it,
so if you're playing it,
like what are you seeing?
Are you seeing on the ground right now?
I see nothing I'm looking around.
I could see down the street there's
some,
some cool places to get more coin or
it's called pokey balls,
which you used to capture.
So these places exist.
How they just like,
they just decided that the things are
there.
It's random,
but what they usually do is they take
certain things in Google maps,
like all their churches are gyms where
you go to workout and stuff like that.
Your pokemons.
Then they take like,
like things like the comedy store and
they put certain like they know it's a
landmark,
so they,
they.
There's a lot going on there.
Like last night,
if you go to the comedy store now,
you haven't been there in a couple of
days.
Every single person's playing,
every single person working there is
playing.
Every comic is.
Everyone's just out there on their
phones.
That's happened so quick.
It's,
it's,
it's huge man.
It's.
I just heard about this like maybe two
days ago,
two days ago,
I saw a couple of pictures
on youtube.
This video of what someone made a fake
application.
I looked like this and it turned out to
be a really good idea that someone to
develop,
develop now,
but
overnight it's doing because it really
hits this nerve in your head of
collecting things and when you're going
like,
look what I have collected and what
will,
where have collectively,
and it's the perfect thing to do when
you're bored.
Like I was in an uber.
I'm just sitting there while we're
driving by the Hollywood bowl and like,
oh,
there's some cool stuff here.
I'm going to get here,
so it's a good thing to do when you're.
You have nothing else to do.
What do you mean?
Get like you just as long as your phone.
It's like you're collecting virtual
items.
items like whoa.
Pokemon chasing investors led Nintendo's
go,
go out there,
make just make it smaller.
Send in $10.
Shares soaring craze added 9 billion in
market value.
Gave me company while Nintendo was
hurting.
It was hurting before this.
Come on.
This is no.
Yeah,
that's the.
Okay,
so you're walking around explaining this
to me.
I'm looking at this person holding their
hand up so they're walking around and
they have like a phone open where the.
They see the image of what's in front of
them.
The pokemon stuff is just sort of
floating around.
Yeah.
Oh my God,
this is crazy.
And then you could grow eggs,
you can share or you can train your
characters to be stronger and then you
can battle other characters at gyms and.
And,
and this is by the way,
is just the first version.
They just,
you know,
they're going to be adding so much to
this and what's interesting to note,
I heard a rumor maybe that the new grand
theft auto is going to be doing the same
thing,
so you're going to be playing grand
theft auto using google maps,
so you're going to be at your house and
your house is going to your house and so
this is just the beginning of this whole
idea of taking Google's information and
giving the people outside.
Good one.
One of the things is that they're
already saying that people are,
are like kids are complaining about sore
legs and like maybe this will be the
video game that people,
people who are addicted to video games.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
that's the only positive thing I see my
neurologist hanging around playing with
each other.
Oh my God,
this is insane.
This is like the comedy store than
comicon in San Diego is going to be a
zoo with this.
I forgot about stuff like that is
fucking insane.
I can't believe I'll just look at her
story.
Is that from being sore?
I also heard that they banned it in San
Francisco,
but I haven't looked to see if that's
true or not.
Like some cities are actually banning it
because people are not paying attention.
Just going into traffic and there was
probably a lot of them on the four.
Oh,
five today.
I saw somebody.
If you think about it,
probably just the next step in what
we're eventually going to get,
which is some sort of a reality that we
can manipulate all the time.
Like this is one part of it.
We're gonna have little games in the
regular reality but you have to look
through your phone to see it,
but how long before that's glasses that
you're wearing like that Microsoft shit.
What was already coming up with that?
What is it called again?
Magic leap.
That's one.
I think that's the Google one.
Microsoft Hollow Lens is are they both
with goggles?
Both augmented reality bit there.
Both developed around augmented reality
and supposedly magically is supposed to
be awesome.
I don't want to say better,
but so no one likes regular reality and
come on if you have a pair of glasses.
If you just put on a pair of glasses
that you put on a pair,
like they live style,
I mean Jesus Christ they live is going
to be real.
You put on a pair of glasses and then
you see and you see all kinds of crazy
shit what you could use but,
but imagine but you can see real part.
That's this morning
dragons if you want to like constantly.
Yeah.
That was google glass or you have a
pair?
No,
no,
no.
That was the one I saw.
That's what I was thinking.
We're doing something with the UFC back
then.
Shogun and Chael Sonnen.
Um,
they were doing something with the USC
and they wanted to get footage.
I noticed some three 60 rigs going
around this weekend.
I wonder what,
what they're gonna do with that.
I just noticed that they were,
there are people walking out with the
fighters and then I noticed during the
fights it was kind of like planted
somewhere near the ring.
If you ever want to talk to the guys
about it and be happy to introduce you
to them.
They're the best.
They know what the fuck to do.
There's all sorts of crazy stuff they've
tried before that they don't do anymore.
Um,
but uh,
I think they're doing four k now too.
That's another new thing
now.
It is pretty.
It's really cool.
Weighted starting have done the porn yet
on the,
on the vr from pokemon to porn.
Same thing.
You could do virtual reality porn.
Yeah.
Apparently.
So there's a,
I forget which website.
One of the main white websites has
somebody like that.
It has free.
That's what those people were doing with
their phones duringj and res thing.
One of the main websites that porn
websites,
pornhub I think has virtual porn,
uh,
now for free.
So you could buy this thing on Amazon,
puts your Samsung note five in there and
it's like a really cheap version of,
you know,
you could do a,
like kind of like Google cardboard.
But uh,
I tried it out the other day
immediately.
I was like,
oh no,
this is the,
this is the one thing that's gonna save
corn.
Because after watching it I felt way
more connected to the girl in the sex.
It was way better,
like a masturbation environment and that
in music videos like his,
I don't know if you've seen Jamie's
friend Cameron Gray,
so when you saying way more connected,
so you felt it wasn't like you were just
watching porn.
It was like,
oh my gosh,
I'm more closer to this girl now because
now I could look at the girl's feet if I
wanted it to or I could look at,
look at the,
you know,
but,
but it,
it was like I was more like after I was
done I was like,
holy cow.
I felt way closer to it.
It was just a way,
a better step up in porn music,
music videos to like his buddy Kevin
Gray has a free app that you can
download a and it's like you're watching
this music video,
but then you could look in the back seat
and see what's going on in the back
seat.
There's like all these different
storylines going on all around and it's
so cool if you haven't seen this shit,
his friend is,
has an amazing music video on the APP
store.
Cameron Gray.
Whoa,
that makes sense.
Man.
I think they're probably gonna do that
with comedy shows too,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
And that's what when you seeing that
stuff that the UFC there,
they probably will have it where you can
just sit there and watch a certain
fights and you can look around.
You could see like dns sitting there.
You could see you yelling.
You know what it might be to me.
I don't know.
I'm just just total speculation,
but it might be the.
Is this the switch to the halfway?
Can you move it to the halfway point
that this part right here,
he's in the backseat of a car or you're
in front seat of a car and there's
somebody like catching this right here
so you can look around and you could see
him get out of the car and you're like,
wait,
where did he go to?
Broken glass?
Yeah,
he's getting something out of the trunk.
Like what's he getting out in the trunk?
You could just look around and then it's
so cool.
You could look forward to seeing that
weird.
There's weird and there's camera and
he's like a lighting something on fire,
but it's neat to this as an a good
example.
This is the first step.
Seeing somebody like a music video do
it.
This is a good example of like it takes
you to a different level of a music
video.
You're not watching a music video.
You get to look at whatever you want in
this music video.
It's the next level of immersion.
Yeah,
but I don't believe that it's going to
take off
till they figure out how to make the
goggles smaller more easier.
Well,
do you think.
Here's the question,
what does it.
What does a movie going to be like?
If this becomes the new thing?
Because like we're used to seeing like
if you want to see a great movie,
right?
You want to see a raging bull,
Great.
Will you sit down and you're watching
this great movie.
It all plays out right in front of you.
When,
when it doesn't,
when it's all in your head,
do you?
Do you still want to be around other
people that are experiencing it?
Like then is everybody walking around?
I think everybody sees something
different.
Yeah,
I think it's gonna be awhile to ever
gets to movies if ever.
Just because if you have the goggles on
after a certain amount of time you have
to take them off.
You're just done.
You know your eyes.
It's too much for your.
Your eyes.
Do you think that it's too much because
it's just not good yet?
Do you think that something they could
work around a little bit of that and a
little bit of.
I think it really fucks with your
everything.
Well they say if you look with a shitty
binoculars,
it's like bad for your eyes look shitty
glass.
That kind of makes sense.
If you're looking through this lens at
this image,
it would have to be like Swarovski
crystal or some crazy shit.
You know what I mean?
Like to like free to be really clear for
your eyes.
Does that make sense?
Because it's straining like,
like I also has to be like 90 frames per
second or it has to be some kind of
frames per second or it makes you sick.
So like there's a video game that's
coming out soon for,
I think x-box replace,
I forget that is a virtual reality game
or when you wear goggles,
but they don't have the frame speed up
fast enough so people are just getting
sick immediately.
What I'm just thinking is like really
good goggles are really good binoculars.
They're real expensive,
you know?
Oh yeah.
And I think if you think about how much
it costs just to buy a pair of
binoculars,
like a really high end pair of
I think about like how much more it
would be for computer attached to that
thing and lucky to have it look really
clear.
Like what is the difference between like
a four k?
What does the,
it's just the resolution difference in
four K it's pretty much like for Hdtvs
make one,
four k screen.
But I've heard that the um,
is it o l e d that that's the best,
like visual that's like saying nowadays
like plasma,
Lcd,
you know,
like that's a kind of TV or kind of a
display.
So yeah.
So.
Oh,
led is not anything special.
No,
that's just like one of the better
organic led organically.
That's what I've been told.
Looks the best.
I think so.
From what I've seen.
And do they make that in four k,
200 percent.
We're in a weird world,
aren't we folks I'm waiting for.
My TV dies.
So strange.
Why don't you give you a TV to like
Josh?
No,
no,
it's a nice TV.
I just,
you know,
I wanted to die so I have a reason to
get a new TV.
I know,
but it's still a top of the line.
Doesn't have
a back when they were awesome.
They were awesome.
Ten years ago.
Yeah.
I have an old ass TV in my gym.
My,
my,
my TV and my gym.
I got in 2003.
This is the same TV.
It's interesting.
It's still there.
Good.
And it's pretty good.
But cheapest.
Fuck today.
Like if I bought it today,
it would be like,
no,
that's garbage.
I was like,
look,
I've got something beautiful lake death.
It goes on the wall.
You were fine.
An old laptop you got laying around.
You're like,
oh my God,
look at this piece of shit.
Just two years ago I got rid of the top
computer with the big.
What's that called?
Yeah,
the tower.
Oh my God.
Even my boyfriend who doesn't get into
this at all,
he was like,
what?
Your Shit's old.
They still use it for like graphic
design and stuff.
Right.
Like with like do they still have great
towers towers,
but it's definitely.
Mine was like a PC.
It was old,
ugly.
It had a back.
That's how you seen that one.
That apple makes it look like a.
Some sort of like an alien.
Hi,
love it.
What is that thing called power as the
computer things to put my daddy out of
business.
What did you call the Mac pro pro?
Yeah,
but it's like it's a piece of sculpture,
like you look at it like glue getting
bought up by.
What's weird is they sell that.
Would that be a bad thing?
Now they don't sell the display this
thing,
so they sell that but they don't sell
display for it anymore.
Okay.
How's that work?
Supposed to use the oldest play that you
had,
they only want to repeat customers.
Jamie.
Price it out to like with the best
specs.
It's amazing how expensive this thing.
Six hundred and 74 bucks.
That's why I've never heard of that
site.
Real quick.
Hold on.
Yeah,
there.
I think the last time I did it,
I think it was like $10,000 or even more
than that.
For the top of the line.
Would someone use something like that
for,
for like photoshop,
video,
video editing,
four k video editing video.
Like literally look at that beautiful
thing yet.
So beautiful.
Built for creativity on an epic scale.
Is that what you said?
Oh Wow.
New power structure.
Whoa.
Well come on man.
You opened the top of that thing.
Tell me if it doesn't look like
something Malians made.
We found this on another planet.
We'd be like,
Holy Shit.
We found the motherland.
This world life is created like a hover
around it or ship it.
I mean a daily folks.
We are in a fucking science fiction
where we really are,
which is just creeping up on us.
So slowly it was the um,
what was it that,
it just showed acoustic levels?
Acoustic global media was so quiet and
clear,
but that was that animation,
like he's printing it out now like
graphics,
you can get six gigabytes dual amd,
a six fuck 10,000 patients looking at it
and thank
you for,
to monitor.
It's actually a lot cheaper than board
or monitor with that.
The difference between what that can do,
a regular Imac can do is just time or is
there anything that,
that can do that.
And I'm just would not be able to do.
It's mostly speed,
but because of the video card it has to
like the,
uh,
the.
I make the best Imac now.
I'm pretty sure it really is just the
best like mobile card you could have
because it would fit inside a laptop.
Like this is way beyond that.
So like I don't think you could do,
you can get four k display because it's
a four k display on the Imac,
but it's still like,
it's the very bottom of it where this
one you can do multiple monitors.
There's some interesting render it
faster too.
There's some,
there's some interesting benchmarks that
I read recently that it actually showed
the Imac is faster than that at certain,
at video editing and stuff like that
because those graphic cards don't have,
are those,
uh,
processors aren't as fast as the
processor that's in the Imac for some
reason.
They have like the IMF has like speed
boost technology were the ones in there
doesn't like.
There was a weird thing I just read
recently about how I was something.
This is making me dizzy.
This whole conversation.
Whatever they did here,
it was 27 inch Imac with retina five k
display.
Yes.
Yeah,
it's much faster.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Isn't that weird?
I just read about this.
So what's the point in that thing?
Just to look good.
I like to look like I know what I'm
doing.
I want to have one of the macros.
It looks sexy,
Jamie.
Not Space.
I'm gives you more space,
doesn't it?
I like space saving.
I didn't mean like digital space.
I meant like,
no for your office,
but that would.
I'm actually give you more space because
it's all in one piece.
Honestly,
I don't know what the reason is for
buying it anymore is.
Yeah,
because the other thing you would have
to get a monitor for.
I have the 27 inch Imac for k retina,
not the five k and it's fast as fuck.
I've NSSD on there and stuff like that.
It renders so fast.
I can't even imagine it being faster,
so there's limitations on the processors
that the IMF could handle it.
This can handle faster processing and it
would be specific to what you're
actually doing.
Like you would.
If we needed one,
we would have to get it built
specifically to some use.
We would have to find for it like not
everyone really needs these.
Right.
Let
me ask you this.
Does apple sell a monitor anymore?
Now they just got rid of it.
That's so ridiculous.
The Imac was the same price as the
Monitor.
No steering wheel.
Figure it out.
We don't.
We don't like windshields.
Get your own.
Once you get it.
Watching a Spanish channel.
I have no idea what you guys talking
about.
Talking about computer stuff,
mainly friends told me that computers
were only have faith.
I don't know what you guys are talking.
What was your dad like when he had a
close the typewriter store and give up
on a dream?
Very,
very upset that it had to be such a
bummer.
Very upset because people who love
mechanical things,
typewriters like that when something
comes along and just takes out a way.
Yeah.
My grandpa,
he built tools specifically for
typewriters that can only fix
typewriters,
but he never marketed them.
He thought he cornered,
like everybody would come to different
Irish mentality because of like hipsters
and stuff.
Our typewriters on an upswing now it's
still not bringing it a little.
It's got a tiny little heartbeat but not
like.
Because they buy them and then they just
put them there for decorative feature.
It's not like,
oh,
I have to get all these letters out
today or whatever it is.
I was actually going to do that very
thing until you just brought it up and
humiliated my idea.
So.
Oh No,
it's what people do.
I mean,
I have it to my sister,
Karen has her bad ass,
but I wouldn't unless it was someone's
cool.
My Dad has ancient ones.
We're right in the beginning.
Typewriter Imac.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
If I could get that from my dad,
he would play with.
He would play with that.
Let's look it attaches to a fucking
screen and old school typewriter.
Convert your favorite typewriter so they
can take yours and they can convert it
to that.
Have to send this to my dad's wife
because she will do that for him.
That is fucking brilliant.
And it's still as the only bought him an
ipad for Christmas,
so he.
He knows that.
Look how it's typing.
It's typing on that flat thing and it
still has the ribbon in there.
What the hell is it?
Need the ribbon for?
I think that's how it's reading.
The type stroll.
Yeah.
Huh?
Okay.
Oh my God.
I can come back.
Maybe that'd be fun to type or write on.
You know,
it might still types on paper too.
Wow.
Oh my God.
This is awesome.
Turn off your monitor for an authentic
experience.
What in the fuck are you saying,
I love this,
this is amazing and I'm sending this to
my dad immediately.
Well,
I sent it to his girlfriend and then she
has to explain how to turn it on and
listen.
We'll give.
They give up that guy's email.
Oh,
here comes a funder.
That's cool.
That's.
Oh I see.
So there's different ones.
One of them works,
it just goes side to side with an ipad.
So the ipad actually pat is what?
We got them for Christmas so that would
be a cool thing to teach them to put it
on there because he literally.
He is saddened by.
Yeah,
I wouldn't progress.
I mean it was all he knew.
Do you know the woody Allen still types
on an old typewriter that you had like
in the seventies?
Yes.
I always seen that and it's kind of
interesting man.
I have heard that a few people,
Tom Hanks to Tom Hanks is big.
I mean,
I don't think he type scripts on it,
but he's big on collecting them and some
of his people were in my dad's
typewriter store like 20 years ago and
they were like,
hey,
we want this because my dad has his old
one,
like that's probably worth a lot of
money,
but my dad just it like
it's not smart.
And so they were like,
yeah,
we'll buy that from you for a lot of
money.
And they.
My Dad went and sell it,
a perverts cabin here.
That's my dad's house.
How dare you.
And we're hoping with Woody Allen with
his ancient keyboard.
It's really interesting actually because
he's like,
he goes over his whole process of how we
kind it is.
It uses just regular paper.
No,
no,
no.
The typewriter.
Is it an underwood or is it a royal he.
He looks like he writes on yellow legal
papers.
I would that.
Is that what that looks like?
Or is it just the lighting?
It looks like it's not big onlining.
He likes everything in yellow.
The setup,
the setup,
the swing.
Oh,
Scott,
ladies and gentlemen,
the coffee yet.
But maybe we are making a comeback
hunter s Thompson type only.
Yeah.
You never know.
I learned how to type.
How about that?
That got so many books and he would
type,
finger,
click,
click.
You never seen him,
dude.
You got to watch Johnny Depp because of
the amazing impression of him in that
movie.
Um,
which one was it?
But yeah,
it was fear and loathing.
But it was also he.
Oh,
that's what it was.
He was the narrator of.
They played it also in the Gonzo life
and times of Dr. Hunter s Thompson.
That's an IBM selectric for it.
That is how he would write like
literally like that.
What does that,
what electric three look like?
That's the one that 100 years,
I guess the ball or the ball.
That's right.
I remember the ball.
That was like the next step up.
Right.
And then Smith Corona came out with kind
of a word processor that my dad was
selling,
but that that's the one that used to get
mad at because when you put labels
through it,
it would seep through and the Google
would come out and it would make
everything stick so it would screw up
the.
That's why my dad said computers are
only a phase because the labels
properly.
It's kind of crazy how quick it
happened.
If you look at the history of the
typewriter,
the typewriter been around,
how dare you not know.
You're right.
I,
you know,
if you.
Okay,
let's guess what,
guess what?
He was teaching us to play with
grenades.
Not Kidding.
What would you,
if you had to guess?
18,
27.
Well that's a killer.
Guests.
But I would go lower.
Go.
Who would you go?
Elena?
17 something?
No,
I think I'd probably go with you because
your dad owns a typewriter store.
So I'm just gonna copy off you.
What did you come up with?
You're right.
It's probably earlier,
but I mean,
I don't know.
I mean,
I could see that one that my dad has.
That was one of the.
Almost at the first,
if I had a guest,
I feel like I feel like you're going to
go with 1797.
Going to ride the line first obtained
patent Britain for a machine
that did something similar to a
typewriter with 17,
14,
18.
Oh,
two.
One was developed and developed them.
18 slash 20.
Oh eight.
The,
another one was developed but 18,
15,
75 and a titan printmaker named
Francisco [inaudible] invented the
scurried into something on a machine
that impresses letters in the paper.
So that's a typewriter base in the
truest.
Yeah.
That's basically a typewriter or will
they have exactly when?
Yeah,
I was pretty impressed.
Like $1,500.
Oh,
printing.
Press me press.
Yeah,
that's what he's saying.
That on the paper,
put the what?
That is a printing press then,
right?
Because the $1,500 a machine that
impressed letters on paper.
I guess what was the year that 15 slash
75.
When was Martin Luther?
Because that was one of the things about
Martin Luther's translation of the
Bible,
right?
Was that he was able to print it.
That's,
that sounds like a stamp that what
you're talking about.
Like this is just like a stamp,
not a Typo.
It's not like going to Kinko's.
No,
no.
I mean this patent at Jamie's talking
about because it's just like putting
imprint on a paper.
Yeah.
So it's not like a press.
Got It.
So hard to remember where.
Whoa,
look at that fucking thing is.
It's same scripture.
Mechanica.
Can you go full screen?
It looks like you see the one in the
middle.
My Dad has.
How does that work?
Oh,
that's.
So you would push down on those buttons
on the top and it would write things
down on the bottom.
Is that what will go on shift?
Look how weird that is.
That crank is your shift,
right?
So eleanor fetus through that.
What is.
Or talk us through the,
like this one.
It feed the paper into the bottom and
then I'm assuming that crank is your
shift to get you across.
Yeah.
The one on the bumper.
Yeah,
what's the one on the bottom?
That's what like the came from the
printing press because that's how you
would press your paper and turn it down
and let it lay coasts.
Taught me how to do that.
How weird.
This place in Columbus called coast side
of.
They have this street to yesteryear and
you can literally go and like make wax
candles and use a printing press.
Did you make Botha?
Uh,
I don't think they have butter there.
That's another part of Ohio,
but they don't make butter in Ohio,
but they do it.
There's another part of the learned that
I wasn't at that place.
Old School stuff is cool man.
I saw this old lady in Montana and this
historic recreation of a house.
There's like this museum of Bozeman in
the Museum of Bozeman.
They have these people that are making
wool yarn and so she's got wool out and
she's running it through the spindle and
as she's running through the spindle,
she's turning it into thread and
attaching more wool to it.
She was explaining how the wool just
clings to other wall that it's got some
sort of a tension thing or an
attractant,
like a little barbs or something
like that.
Something that sticks out and like and
you rub the wools together.
They kind of cling to each other and so
she was doing this all by hand and foot
like old school.
He and making and doing it like in real
time,
like she'd pull out these big tufts of
this wool that just sheered from a lamb.
She'd take it and she just started
attaching it and she's talking to us and
pumping this pedal and making this wall.
It's pretty bad ass man.
Yeah,
I've done that before that.
They do that a lot.
There's a lot of that shit in Ohio and
they also Williamsburg,
West Virginia,
like that whole town where they have
like real fights.
They have real blacksmiths and it goes
to.
Yeah,
people get weird what recreation's,
but that was cruel.
It was pretty cool because it is part of
the history thing.
You can't get mad.
I mean that's not weird.
Like the civil war stuff's weird and
they recreate that.
It is uncomfortable for all of us,
but some of us just saying,
but it is,
it is a weird thing,
but if part of the history,
so don't you think with the history of
people recruiting war,
like we don't know what happened are
coming over the top.
They're pretending to reward.
Trying to fight to keep their slaves.
They might get shot at my dad shot me
with a musket,
but what I'm saying is that like it's.
I don't know,
it's strange.
It's a strange thing to recreate that,
but at least I don't know.
I don't know.
But at least this lady Megan,
this wool,
like when she's making this wool,
now you know how they did it.
Like you could watch,
oh I'm watching her do it,
you know,
like it's not a lost skill because we
would.
Oh yeah.
Otherwise you know,
you and I if you and I were like,
how do they make wool yarn?
Fuck,
I don't know.
How the fuck do they do it?
Left us with a bunch of wool and we're
like,
dude,
we got to make yarn.
We'll do.
They tell us.
Oh No,
we have to figure it out.
Fuck sure.
There's a youtube video.
Yeah,
but what if you couldn't get online?
What if you're just sitting in a room
and empty room with a pile of bull?
What are you going to survive?
You're not going to make star not going
to make clothes for you.
Okay.
No,
I'm just.
I'm just thinking about that.
Like how would you.
What would you do that?
Oh my God,
there I am.
The old spinster.
Yeah.
They used to think those old William
were cursing them.
That's exactly sleeping.
Beauty came from.
I really liked my mom and dad used to
click singer sewing machines.
The old ones were old iron wines and you
have to like get new rubber stopper.
Rubbers gotten bad,
but my could.
In Ohio there's so many barns and
they're about to tear down these barns
and they have barn sales.
We'd just go and like,
I see anything you want in there.
My Dad would go to them and just take
all the singer sewing machines because
they always had sewing machines in them
for that kind of reason.
Like shaving sheep and making.
Yeah,
I mean I would be terrified to do that,
but the people that did it for years,
yeah,
they did it for a long fucking time and
my sister had bad at that.
Has that almost exact one right there.
If you could make clothes,
go back to that one.
If you can make
clothes with that one that you're
pumping with your feet.
And my grandma had one of those.
My grandma said,
pick one like that I think are maybe up
there.
My grandma had a bunch of cool old stuff
like that.
Yeah.
I used to love just broke down and my
foot is your grandma.
Does she do that?
I don't really remember her making any
clothes.
I don't remember.
I mean maybe she did.
She probably did.
I just don't remember.
I remember,
uh,
she was ill like the last years of her
life,
so I mostly remember that unfortunately
because it was all during the formative
years.
But that thing,
go back to that Jamie Lukow.
Beautiful.
That thing is like the craftsmanship and
the design and like if you look at the
gold that's in the a sewing machine
thing itself,
it's so pretty.
It is really cool.
My sister designed costumes for,
her daughter is a dancer and she would
do a recital every year and Karen also,
my older sister would go and like while
the shows were happening,
she would stitch stuff up as well.
And a couple a years ago she had to like
straight pins in her and she was like
helping their kids.
You know,
they're young.
So Karen's like putting all the stuff
together.
She was fixing somebody's thing and
somebody called her and she went and she
wanted.
She swallowed the Pan Pan or long.
My crazy sister to do.
There's nothing you can do.
What's shut my mother is like,
is that big rusting in your body,
have to absorb it and somebody's going
to absorb it.
Is it stainless steel?
I guess I could take a long foot.
Is she getting into her lung?
They saw it are open like a fish.
Get it out of there.
Yeah,
cut me crazy and making shit.
It's been.
It's been a while.
Maybe it's more than two years,
but I'm saying the wrong ones,
but I remember she had blood work done
or something done and they were like,
Hey,
do.
She was some metal something,
whatever.
What about when she goes to the is what
happened?
Oh my God,
that's so crazy.
I don't think she's had any problem at
the airport.
It could have got stuck on the way down.
Easy.
And then in her lung,
something crazy.
Oh my God.
My crazy sister.
But you.
That's Karen.
She's always doing like 5 million things
at once.
So see this.
Of course she did that.
Of course they haven't heard czar,
but her costumes look great.
What a weird feeling.
Mostly walk around with a knowing her
like we want to put a magnet in her
mouth and see if it comes back up,
but it seems like she could come off
wrong and could just rip something open
or something,
God forbid.
But yeah,
I don't think for the big,
God forbid you cannot think of them.
Did not think about dom arrera.
It's true golf a bit.
What's the South Philly?
It's how we talk.
Yeah,
everybody.
So it's so dom fitbit,
he used to make fun of my grandma.
She was saying,
Oh God forbid it's a sin and a shame
with that kid.
Looks like what an awful
thing.
It's knowing what you know now.
Knowing what you know now.
Let me ask you both this question.
Knowing what you know now,
what time would you like to go back?
If you could.
If there was a time machine you can go
back to like the 19 fifties and just run
shit for a little while.
Those dorks in on enough and back then
you can just go back and you would know
what you know now,
but going back exactly.
Oh Shit.
What year would it be?
Nineteen teens.
50.
So maybe I could lead a charge.
You could vote in the fifties when he
was suffering.
Now what am I saying?
For us,
I wouldn't want to give back.
I want to go.
Yeah,
definitely.
Not.
Definitely not.
I just watched it back to the future yet
it yesterday and it was horrible.
It was.
I know.
I thought it was fascinating.
I saw back to the future two with my
kids at a movie theater.
And you thought it was terrible.
I loved it.
Oh No.
I wouldn't want to live back in that
time.
No,
definitely.
I love that movie.
The future too.
I,
I didn't.
I don't think I ever saw it.
Oh,
I think I only saw one.
I know I did see two.
I remember it was great and that was
this year I think,
right?
Like 2015?
Yeah,
2015.
Weird.
When you walk into like,
oh,
that was.
They were in the future.
It was a hard time.
So off they missed everything.
They,
everybody thought it was going to be
spaceships.
Everybody thought I was going to be
hovered for thought I was going to be
mechanical things.
No,
it's Pokemon pokey.
Mon is invaded the world.
Asian of privacy.
Exactly.
That's what it is.
It's some sort of a connection between
all of us in a weird,
sneaky way.
It's going to get it in with a game and
we're going to get used to it just like
you're used to.
Now people are holding up their phones
and take pictures of things and we're
used to,
uh,
you know,
people texting each other while they're
driving.
Like all this stuff is,
it's all,
it's inevitable.
It's going to be all a part of us.
We're just going to figure it out.
Trying to figure out a way to absorb us
right now and the best way to suck us in
as a game.
You don't think it observable absorbs.
That's right.
Yeah.
But it's even,
it's deep and it's not going to go
further.
Yeah.
Like,
technology's not gonna stop and go.
You know what?
I think we're good.
I think we've achieved a certain level
of success with people.
We know that they love us.
They're going to keep us around.
Yeah.
Nobody stays there are always looking
for the next best thing.
Like you always yell.
Where are the flying cars?
Flying cars were in the jet packs.
Jet Packs all of it.
Yeah.
Well what was the mechanical things?
What everybody expected?
Because the mechanical things where the
biggest leaps,
like think about before there was a car
before there was a car and then
afterwards a car.
Whoa,
how nutty.
I mean look what the fuck happened.
People just came across the country on
wheels and built fucking houses
everywhere and they drive with shit back
and forth and they're shipping things on
trucks and food on trucks and you can
get food to places that could ever get
it before.
So that's a game changer when they
invented the car and that's just a
machine.
So we,
I think all of us growing up in that
era,
like in our time we looked at like we
thought it was going to be a machine,
it's going to be some crazy robot.
It was going to be a jet pack.
We're going to be something that showed
us that we're living in the jetsons,
but no state something,
something no one ever saw coming
information way information.
I remember my grandma telling me she was
so afraid of cars and the fact that my
grandpa drove like a maniac.
He probably drank and drove because it
was,
you know,
long time ago and she was so afraid she
would lay on the back seat on the floor
and just her and her best friend would
lay on the back and I'm like,
wow.
Like I would never think to be afraid of
cars.
You getting anything,
you know what I mean?
Getting any car,
it's awesome.
You know,
it works,
you know,
it's great.
But it was still coming up
from my grandma.
Well Byron bowers,
funny,
hilarious dude.
Great fucking guy.
So he's going to be on here in a couple
of weeks.
Byron,
his grandmother remembers someone in her
family telling her a story about them
remembering the cotton gin.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
Crazy.
I mean this is a direct connection.
Like she,
like his family goes straight back to
slavery.
Like he,
they can track it.
They remember they remember the people
that are picking cottons.
Grandma,
this is great grandma.
You know,
there's still cotton pickers.
Do you know that?
Of course y'all sure it never went away.
It never went away.
There was a,
I forget,
there was a black guy and he goes,
I'm a cotton picker,
is there was a video all about it and
then it showed all of his friends
working and there's just like,
Hey,
what's up?
And it's funny how you think that,
oh no,
you're not allowed to even talk about
cotton anymore to do it now.
But yeah,
it's a weird job for black dudes
gravitate towards.
It's like,
why did you think you were a rebel
against,
you know?
Oh,
you know,
I know.
But Paul Mooney used to tell us crazy
stories and I remember one time we had
this manager,
I forget his name,
there was so many managers at the comedy
store,
but Paul would tell me all these crazy
stories.
He was raised by his grandma,
who was his mom.
Her mom was a slave,
literally.
So,
so he would tell stories and if you
think about it,
I mean,
Paul's in his eighties,
so his grandma could.
It was Paulo Have Paula Paul that old,
I think he's his late seventies.
Possibly add.
Yeah.
And um,
but he would tell me all these stories
in the manager was like slavery that
they haven't had like thousands of
years.
I was like,
are you high?
He was serious.
And I was like,
what?
And he goes,
well,
at least 500.
Oh my God.
But we didn't have google.
I couldn't say,
hey idiot,
google it.
I was just like,
are you crazy?
But I,
I just walked away from him like I
because I was like,
I'm either going to strangle him.
Like he just for me saying that it was
less than 200 years ago.
At that point he didn't believe me.
But there's some things that people say
like that,
just that like wasn't that's what you
want it to be two
years ago.
That's what you want it to be.
I know what you're doing.
Like why do you think that that's the
case?
Like people say Weird Shit.
Like,
like I had a discussion with a guy long
fucking time ago about the civil war and
he was talking about the economic impact
it was,
they were going to cripple the farms.
Like is an economic more and they forced
him in a corner where they had.
It was about slavery.
It was just about,
yeah,
if you don't want to pay people and
you're making them work,
that's economics.
People are like that.
They like to get paid for work.
So yeah.
In that sense it was an economic issue,
but people repeat that because they can.
They could drink.
No.
Yeah.
Well,
at least fucking liberals try telling
that to them.
They don't want to hear it.
They don't want to hear.
It was about echo.
Listen,
these people who were slaves allow than
were treated very well.
I don't have.
You know,
there's a lot of that roots,
that propaganda,
that movie,
that l Ron Hubbard,
whoever wrote that shit,
that guy he wrote,
a lot of them were good friends with the
white folks.
Sometimes they interbred.
They often interbred the master would
pick himself a good woman and she would
be treated better than the rest.
So you know,
how much different is that than working
at Burger King?
I mean,
come on.
There's a lot of those dudes out there.
They were always out there.
I didn't know we were going to bring my
dad back up.
People are fucking completely insane.
Yeah,
it's true.
There is a lot of people that are just
and they booked.
The thing is like when a guy says I was
about economics,
it's about economics.
You don't want it to be that.
So they want there to be a bunch of
silly people.
They don't.
They don't want like slavery has been
abolished in 18,
65 and people went to war over it.
Yeah.
That's so recent.
Fuck,
that's recent.
You know I was born in [inaudible] 67.
Okay.
So it's two years,
200 years rather before I was born.
Think about that for 100 years.
One hundred years before I was born.
Yeah.
Think about that.
No,
that's,
that's nothing.
I mean you think.
Yeah.
My grandma was 93 when she died in 1965.
Doesn't even sound right when you say
it.
There was only 140 something years ago.
He like,
Nah,
it was more than that,
right?
It was more than that.
Right.
It's more than that,
right?
Oh my God.
Crazy creeps.
We were,
we had slaves just to fucking couple
hundred years ago was I had family that
lived to be $100,
so that's an easy number.
Jesus Christ.
That's cool.
That is so strange that that was so
recent.
And in places where it was like real
prep.
Now stop and think of that,
right?
Think of places where like slavery was
real prevalent,
right?
People lived on the slavery,
they had it,
there was,
lynchings was all that kind of crazy
shit and they'll think that all goes
away just 150 years ago.
Yeah.
And they got to recover.
So all racist,
grandpappy,
racist Paul Pol Pot Pie Pie.
They get
to gail.
Tell you what we're gonna do.
We're gonna put our foot down.
I'll tell you what we're going to do.
We're in stop hold his interbreeding
Chelsea handler did something on her
show,
that first one on netflix where she went
and visited places like that where it's
still.
And it was so I was like,
oh.
And she's having conversations and
they're doing what you're saying with
economic.
And I'm like,
what the.
And she's like,
wait a minute.
And like trying to schedule that,
but it's just,
you're right,
like this blinders will,
they don't blame,
don't look into it and that's what they
want to hear.
So it's,
it's what they talk about.
It's a fascinating thing when people do
that,
when people don't consider the
possibility of another point of view.
Yeah,
you can't be that close minded.
That's insane.
I mean if you look at how many people
have benefited from slavery,
stopping,
like the idea that anybody's out there
somehow or another sample we'll need
about that.
Keeping this corn business going.
Need someone to pick this here corner.
I couldn't pick it on a cell phone
because we're trying to keep a family
friend trying to support community.
Fuck,
that's crazy.
Living in those places like living in
spots where it was like insanely racist
for hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
of years.
Right.
And then to expect that to just shut off
and turn around within our lifetimes,
it's almost amazing that people aren't
more racist.
Well,
Philadelphia's pretty racist.
Boston's pretty racist.
Only parts of Boston hearts,
Boston,
like the center Boston is very liberal,
democratic,
very progressive.
But there's a lot of townies that don't
like the my parents growing up.
You couldn't date a Italian Irish yet?
Well,
they don't like people would freak out.
They don't like people that are
different than them.
They get mad and Italian.
Irish like that was a big one.
You and I were the dirtiest of the
mutts.
I'm 100 percent Irish.
You think you are.
You've had so much dick in you from
Italian guy.
I'm representing every country.
I watched the Olympics and go,
I've been there.
Yeah.
Philly is similar in a lot of ways.
Like Philly,
New York,
Boston,
New Jersey.
They all have like a different feel to
them.
But what's similar is they're hardy
people that are living in tough climates
and they're the children of the children
of immigrants.
For the most part.
Most of my neighbors growing up spoke
Italian or I mean we came over.
I don't remember how far back.
I think my great,
great on my dad's side and then great,
great.
Great.
On my mom's side came from Ireland.
That's,
that's a lot of the people that I grew
up with who was always like their dad's
dad or someone will say it was my
grandparents on both sides came from a
my
parents,
my mom side,
it was all Italian and my dad's side is
half Irish and half Italian.
One from Italy,
one from Ireland,
but there were all fresh off the boat.
Just bad Irish.
Just staring in each other.
A little monkey.
She wasn't even supposed to be on this
continent.
Baby girl,
me in prison.
My person in your buddy.
My Mom's good at that one.
Ten,
10,
and my dad's dad was one of 15.
Good Lord.
There was a lot of us out there.
We do.
They like to keep them to.
Yeah,
we've got a lot of kids,
gang.
Oh kids.
My Mom's sister had 10 kids to.
Oh my God.
Well,
the picnics,
picnics,
not picnics.
They don't.
They didn't like mob scenes like that.
Park rent a hall.
Twenty six people would indoors.
How many families want?
My mom's mom had four kids.
She was orphaned at a very early age.
She had four kids,
so she wants to have like a real tight
knit family.
Four kids,
27 grandchildren,
45 great grandchildren.
When she passed away 11 years ago,
I had a lot of periods in your only
time.
Tampax.
Super Fertile.
You could probably get them from her
other sisters.
Yeah,
you can.
And I.
My mom had a hysterectomy.
She's still nervous.
She's like around.
That's so crazy.
Such a giant number of human beings to
come out of a couple of folks.
How many other people are going to get
bread out of that?
Yeah,
we're good.
We,
we slowed,
we slow because we're 10 and then we
only.
I only have 10 nieces and nephews,
but my little sister did just get
married so my might add on the other.
My aunt joy,
she had 10 kids and they have I think 15
or 17 nieces and nephews.
You know what I mean?
Like hide.
So they did the bigger we were half and
half,
half of us had kids and half of us
didn't.
Half of us were like,
you know what?
We're going to stop this bloodline.
Maybe that's why you don't want kids.
She's been around too many people.
True.
Or it could be those bad decisions I
made with dating.
No,
I'm just kidding.
Oh no,
they're good.
I love kids.
I do,
but I,
I just,
I don't know.
We don't have my own.
If I for my own,
I don't want for me,
like when I go home I'm with my nieces
and nephews all the time,
hang out with them all the time.
I even had my niece Alexa came out here
to live for a little while because she's
into producing and editing,
like that's just graduated college.
So like I'm very close with my kids.
I call them my kids and uh,
but I just,
for myself,
I didn't want to make total sense.
And also the,
just the sheer numbers of people that
you've been around for so long,
you're like enough fucking people making
more people.
Jesus Christ.
I mean,
I wonder how much of that pull to family
is that,
you know,
to create some bond with people that
you're like deeply,
deeply close to.
And I wonder if you grow up with so many
people like you have that bond gets
drowned out.
But the way we grew up on top of each
other by tight,
we are tight.
Let's not get crazy.
But we are tight.
Oh,
I could imagine 10 kids growing up in a
pilot that I bet if one of you gets in
trouble,
fucking hailstorm.
We had nobody wanted to fight one
because she had a fight.
And I have six brothers so it's like I
shared a room with them.
I stayed in the most important thing
growing up.
What?
People you.
Yeah,
like if shit goes down,
like if it was raining out,
people would knock on our door.
Like let's go in there.
It's like a playground.
Hilarious.
There's always something to do in the
Kerrigan House,
you know,
like it was just in the St.
just never going to happen.
And yet you're right,
you're right.
Yeah.
Now you know,
now that people have two kids and they
tag out and that's fine.
That's just that kids aren't running
around the street.
That was my favorite.
Like we really were outside and that's
when I kind of what this pokemon thing,
I'm excited that people are outside and
I was home a couple of weeks ago.
I will watch these kids fight and play
in the playground and it was just like.
I still think certain areas do it.
It doesn't exist.
Well,
I think that when.
No,
definitely not walking.
I mean people in New York walk way more
than the ones out here,
like already loves doing sets than
walking home to his apartment.
It's my favorite thing to do in New
York.
Do you really?
My favorite thing and I've walked from
all the way the upper west side all the
way down versus go to the gym and then
have like a normal person did do that.
I did go to the gym that day.
We go to crunch gym and we kill it and
then that night I walk home.
I do enjoy like hiking.
I do enjoy like walking up hills in
nature and shit like that.
I enjoyed walking around the streets.
I'm like,
this fucking airs,
tainted,
breathing in brake dust,
texts and drives right into you.
Fuck,
that was alert as if you're driving,
walking.
She and a couple of people running
lights lately.
It's Buki.
It's very strange.
I stopped me.
We saw a girl get hit by a car.
I don't even know how it happened.
It was like we were in the car.
Guy was making a left girls crossing the
street.
This guy obviously in the wrong making
the left.
She was on her phone,
but she,
before she crossed,
he made the left.
He must have been on his phone and he
did not hard,
but they're like,
he realized and it was just like she
went down like a sack of potatoes and me
and my niece were like,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
Like we just got out the help because we
didn't know what.
How do you not see that?
How did he not see her?
How did people sometimes are not fucking
paying attention,
doesn't make any sense.
Just drifting off and people just so
tired.
They're like barely paying attention to
what they're doing.
They're just working all day and they're
so tired.
I walk home from the store a lot,
maniac.
I try to because the parking that dry,
if I just have a spot at the store,
sometimes I'll just.
Or if I do the store in the factory
because then you can walk down the
street.
So I mean,
and a lot of times I'll,
if I have both,
I will park at the store,
walk to the factory and then walk back.
Well,
sunset is if there's going to be a spot,
there's like,
what else?
Melrose and sunset in Santa Monica
Boulevard.
People walked down there and then people
walk on the promenade,
that little Santa Monica and they walked
down there.
Venice people walk around Venice.
But when you walk in Hollywood,
people look at you like,
Oh God,
what's wrong with her?
Like walking around with some hookers.
I have a car and I am a hooker.
I have to make extra money in there.
It is weird when you're walking around
or driving around in Hollywood,
you don't see a lot of people walking.
No.
Only on certain areas,
like you said at the Hollywood
boulevard,
if they're going to sightsee,
whatever.
Wonder how much that's shaped.
Like how,
uh,
what,
what the personality of people that live
in La is the fact that people were in
cars early on because the transportation
system sucks.
It's terrible.
But like I didn't have a license when I
first moved here.
I had no,
I mean I tried to learn how to drive and
I tried to get my sister Karen to take
me to get a license,
but she missed the exit and she got
angry so she literally was like,
God kill us all.
And I was like,
oh my God,
anger issues.
Seriously,
I hate you.
So forgive her.
I love my sister.
Yeah,
bring it up to her every now and then.
I was onstage and I told that story and
she was here with her daughter visiting
for Mother's Day and I started to tell
the story and I heard her go,
oh,
this story.
No,
we're tired.
Like she was my.
She taught me how to swim.
She taught me everything.
I said,
Karen,
she's 10 years older and we look exactly
alike.
Wow.
It's like the weirdest thing.
And her daughter,
when she came out here,
everybody was like,
Oh,
is that your daughter?
I'm like,
no.
And they're like,
don't lie to us.
You abandoned your kid to come to la.
I was like,
yeah,
I'd abandoned a kid to do this.
Right?
Like,
who would do that?
I would never known to do that.
And he's like.
And Dave Taylor was like,
you guys have the same overbite?
I'm like,
what do you worked for?
CSI?
What does that even mean to Taylor
swift?
She's my niece that's.
He's like,
no,
you gave her up being crazy.
He wasn't the only one.
There was a co,
he's the only one that said the
overbite.
That's all.
But anyway.
So yeah,
she uh,
she's my sister's side,
but I didn't have a license until two,
three years after being here.
So walking was awful.
Awful because you wait for the bus and
they just have their own schedule.
They got the juice to the east coast
where you can take a bus to Boston and
come back,
like of fucking characters.
Were you running into on the public
transportation system in la?
So many.
One time I remember I got in trouble
because I was waiting tables at the
store and the manager was like,
if you're late one more time because I'm
always like,
it's my thing,
whatever.
My grand mom used to yell at us for it.
I don't know what happens.
But anyway,
so my grandma,
my grandma actually called me you
people.
I'm like,
really?
People that's so racist.
But anyway,
so she was like,
if you're late one more time.
So I specifically came I think an hour
early I could have just walked,
but I was waiting for the bus and uh,
I waiting for the bus and I was talking
to this black guy.
He was funny.
He was like,
damn a girl like you,
you should be in a cadillac.
And I was like,
you got one,
like,
you know,
I'm like playing with,
like talk to people.
And he did he have like a,
you know,
a nice little curl going.
So I know what he did.
I tell what he did,
but it's not my business.
So I was just talking to them because I
was trying to get you to go to work for
him.
No,
he was literally just talking.
Then the bus came.
As I went to get on the bus,
they pulled me off the bus.
Two undercover cops.
They had him on the ground with guns in
his face.
I'm like,
what's the.
And they grabbed my bags.
She started going through my bag.
I was like,
you can't go through my bag,
you.
I started panicking.
I was like,
you can't go through my bag,
you know me?
And they're like,
why were you talking to him as he tried
you work for him?
I'm looking at,
I have a giant overage size gray sweater
on black tights,
a comedy store t shirt.
I'm like,
what do I know?
I'm not working for him.
See that girl with her pussy hanging out
of her skirt.
She's working for him,
not me.
Like they were on the other side of the
street and he's like,
get down.
So they're screaming at me and are going
through my bag and I'm like,
you really can't go through my bag.
I'm panicked and then things just
started screaming,
asking questions,
did you or is he trying to recruit you?
Do you work for him?
And he's literally on the ground guns
drawn.
He did nothing to me.
All he did was say I should be in a
cadillac.
That was it.
And so I was like,
dude,
you gotta calm down,
and I was like,
I'm going to be late for work and I'm
going to get fired in this God's good
guns in his face and I'm worried about
my weight and tables at the comedy
store.
So then finally they let him go and I
was so pissed and I'm getting my stuff
and put my bag together and I'm like,
this is bullshit.
But I was afraid to talk back to a cop.
So I was like,
oh,
it was like inside me.
And then they were like,
you want us to drive you to work?
And I'm like,
Oh yeah,
that's great.
You're going to drive me to work.
And if so,
when we pull up,
I'll tell Mitzi shore I got picked up
for prostitution and that's why I had to
get here late in about 15 minutes.
But Debbie,
no,
I took,
I did take the ride,
but Mitzi wasn't there that night.
Thank God.
But Debbie,
the manager did see me get out of a cop
car and she's like the,
she's undercover waitress.
That's why she doesn't get fired even
though she's late.
She's still crazy.
Mitzi let me be the boss because I was
always late.
She's like,
okay,
fine.
But you know,
that's a crazy story because it shows
people what it's like to be poor and be
dealt with by the cops when they know
that you don't,
you can't do anything.
Couldn't do anything.
I was like,
it'd be honest,
I like,
I just don't.
I panicked when they go through your bag
or something like that.
Everything goes through your head and
you're like,
what am I packing tonight?
Am I this right?
Like what am I doing?
You know,
like scared and,
and,
but you have no rights most of the time.
It's crazy.
It's crazy that you don't have any
rights.
I don't think that's legal know,
but if you resist and you fight back,
you're going to
get hit.
I've been,
I've been thrown in the back of a paddy
wagon.
I've tried both ways.
It can't.
I've seen guys get beaten good friends
like,
like and just in a nightclub just from
resisting and it was a stupid thing we
were doing and you know,
I seen it.
I've seen both ends.
Yeah.
Jobs are stressed the fuck out.
That's what I'm saying.
In a bad situation like that,
like in your situation like that was,
it was crazy ridiculous.
All you're doing is talking to a guy and
then you're getting on a bus.
In fact they grabbed you like that,
but how many white girls talked to that
guy that aren't working for them and
their defense.
So for sure this bitch knows it.
Look how comfortable she is with them.
She's not even freaking out.
She's got to be a hooker.
She's like,
she's joking around with him.
You got a cadillac,
you got one.
Like they're negotiating terms of their
contract.
He was funny,
but they figured if you talking to a
pimp and you're not freaking out,
for sure,
there's got to be something wrong with
you.
I'm not saying he might not get another
girl who's like,
oh,
this girl can be molded.
Her mind can be molded,
you know,
I'm not going to turn tricks that
overbite.
All of a sudden I feel like my overbite
has gotten bigger.
You know?
It's weird.
The Guy can't take ag,
couldn't recruit girls and have them do
sex for money for him and protect them.
That's what a pimp does to prostitutes
and prostitutes and illegal.
Right.
But you could recruit girls to make
videos of them having sex.
Like you can have people that can even
pay you immediate money though.
Is it?
Prostitution is like white and taste.
I can totally be immediate money.
If you make people pay,
make people pay to have sex with
somebody.
Somebody make a video of it saying,
but it's just what my point is like
pimps right now,
but the certain pimping that's like the
word pimping is very strange.
Like you decide that women are too
vulnerable to except a mentor figure and
the strong sexually overcharged black
man with the feathers and the gold
chains.
Like that's,
that's essentially with this.
Right.
But if he owns like a brothel in like
Nevada or something like that,
like that's okay.
Pay Taxes.
There's a less dangerous for the girl.
Oh yeah.
So it was poor.
She could get done.
I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with any of it,
but I'm like,
it is.
Prostitution is a fucking weird one.
It is a real.
Pimping isn't even weirder one because
that guy's not fucking anybody.
That's where it's even weird.
He just got a bunch of friends with
money that likes to give him money.
He talks to these girls who do stuff
that's illegal.
He does stuff with the girls.
Okay.
But he's not doing anything to get that
money.
Right.
If you're a real pimp,
I don't think you're doing anything
wrong.
You're sitting back,
sitting back,
you're Maxon.
And at firs on
Vincent,
you know you've got long nails.
Just show everybody that you can't do
work.
Maybe they have a whole lot of those
dudes like pimps up hoes down.
They had many long nails.
Nails.
Yeah,
they had,
but there was other.
The other nails were substantially
longer than the average person works
nine to five job,
so they have this whole thing going on.
What do they do?
An illegal.
All they're doing illegal as being a
pimp.
C,
the actual act,
the illegal act is being done by the
woman.
The woman is the woman is a prostitute.
She is deciding as a grown adult to go
out and have illegal sex with men and
then comes back and brings the money to
the pimp and the pimp did really do
anything.
He just got the girl to give him his
money.
A lot of times these girls are under age
two.
Well,
that's the problem.
that's a very different story.
Only flattering thing about the story is
that the guy thought I was under fishes.
Oh,
look at it until it gets manicures.
He's fresh look or they're not that big.
He's fresh.
That's a pretty long stretch.
I love Snoop Dogg.
He can do.
He can do no wrong.
What he did the other day,
it's amazing the way he led the.
It wasn't a protest,
it was like we're going to go talk to
our officials and figure it out,
how we can make peace,
how we can do this.
And that was good because having the
game did it and a lot of people
followed.
Yeah.
Snoop Dogg's.
Very peaceful dude.
Very peaceful.
Very smart man.
That nailed thing is weird though.
And then yeah.
Even my now I don't even get manicures.
Sometimes pimps up,
hoes down.
Pimps up.
Hoes down with a really great.
Yeah.
I used to watch it on repeat with Freddy
Soto because we were obsessed with
fillmore slim.
Yeah.
He was slick.
That's what the guy looked like that was
sitting on the bench and I always
wondered was it him?
I don't know.
What year was it was in 1993.
[inaudible] 93.
It was way before that movie with your
ice tea.
Remember?
I was in it.
He was in it and it went on this long
route.
Rant about how he is just a pimp and
he's not really a rapper.
I never really been a rapper.
I'm bitter about wrapping big law.
What was her name?
Be Big.
How about Mr White folks are areas right
there.
This Guy Mr. White folks.
White folks.
Oh my God.
He was hilarious.
Reckless eyeballing.
It's crazy.
This show,
this documentary was one of my favorites
and then the other guy we liked film
fillmore slim.
I just loved how he would come to la.
He got his.
All his girls got arrested.
He was like,
you thought that was my first track.
I got another track quit and he was on a
payphone.
He brought into the team.
They took out the beach here and then he
sent the 18 down second.
So y'all not the long hose.
Dr Ron Hoes like they were playing busy
booking nam.
Watch this.
I was like,
yes,
I love this guy.
They played games.
We were obsessed with that show that a
documentary.
Obviously there's sadness to it,
like no one wants a girl to be a
prostitute.
So much sadness to the girl gets zero
percentage.
That's what I remember learning that and
I was like,
what?
Let me ask you this,
honestly and truthfully isn't,
it isn't a lot of what's wrong with
prostitution?
Two things.
One,
our idea about it like are forbidden,
taught like it's forbidden.
It's taboo.
You're not supposed to get money for sex
and to the fact that it's illegal
because if it was legal,
Oh God,
the same.
Probably the same amount of people would
be doing it no more,
no more.
I think it would be more the same amount
of people would be doing prostitution or
going to prostitutes.
I'm saying doing prostitution,
doing it just would be busier,
busier,
but at the same be the same people that
wrong.
But you know what I mean?
Heidi,
feeling it probably would be more people
because I know a lot of girls that will
do it.
If it was illegal,
you know,
I can calm them,
would be working with Kim is what I'm
saying.
See if it was legal.
I think it would be.
If it was accepted in legal,
I think it would definitely more people
would do it.
You know,
I think if I was a girl,
um,
I would definitely fuck guys that I was
attracted to for money track guy and he,
you know,
and he was like,
look,
I don't want a relationship,
but I'll give you two grand if you
fucking sick.
Even in a relationship.
One time I remember like getting in an
argument with my boyfriend because after
we had sex he gave me money and I was
inappropriate and he was like,
what?
But it was for something and like he was
like,
oh,
you're going to go get this today.
I forget what it was.
I don't know if it was something for me,
I forget what it was,
but it was money yet.
And I was like prostitute.
Like when he left I was like,
oh,
that didn't feel that bad.
Should do this more often.
If you really liked guys kidding me,
we were in a relationship,
but it was just a weird moment.
Like I was like,
oh right.
But I'm saying if you love the guy,
like you get to things,
you like Dick and then money.
Yeah.
That order.
Usually people get paid for jobs that
they love or people can pay for the jobs
that they hate.
Yeah.
How about getting paperwork done?
They love.
Yeah.
Like movie stars get paid.
They get paid for being moved and they
enjoy it.
They love it.
They're out there acting explosions
going on.
Get more with your pace it out.
Yeah,
let's do it.
I'm sorry.
That's where I brought it.
Come on.
Let's say that we're going to rally to
make this legal so that Kim and I have
something to do.
It's eventually going to be legal.
You know what's interesting and might
turn to be like a virtual thing before
it becomes legal.
If what I'm been thinking about what you
were saying about the poor and the
virtual poem with the headsets on being
so interactive and immersive.
I'm like,
yeah,
of course.
That's just what's going to happen and
they're just going to figure out a way
to make it.
They're going to figure out a way to
stimulate your body.
Like that's the only thing that's
missing.
Like once they stimulate your mind,
maybe they will be able to put you in
some sort of a trance.
Will you feel like it's stimulating your
body already in a trance.
Also looking at some thing that they're
selling really recently got,
I'm trying to remember this because I
saved it,
but I didn't read it,
but it was talking about some new device
that's able to stimulate certain areas
of the mind from,
from the outside of your head,
like they did a whole episode of radio
lab about this sort of technology a long
time ago,
I want to say like two years ago maybe.
And it was really interesting because it
was about,
um,
how they stimulate different parts of
your scalp and through doing so it
allows you to remember and learn things
way quicker through electricity.
Maybe this is it,
nine volt nirvana as the episode of
Radio Lab.
If you guys have never listened to radio
lab,
it's fucking awesome.
It's one of the best podcasts in the
world.
And uh,
it's,
it's really interesting.
And this is like one of my favorite
episodes because it's about this girl,
she,
this is how it starts off.
She works for this,
I should say woman,
she's a woman.
She has a good job.
She's a
sure child.
I'm not good.
I say girl boy for adults all the time
and I should fix that.
Yeah.
Who Care?
Full battery.
Yeah.
So she went there to um,
this place that train snipers,
snipers skills,
um,
thing.
And what,
what it is,
is a video game,
a virtual reality thing.
So you put on the headset or you know,
they,
they take her through the thing with a
gun and she shoots at all the different
targets and all these different events
happen in front of her.
And when it plays out,
after it's over,
they tally up your score.
So she does that in a normal way.
And then they stimulate the outside
areas of her brain.
She goes in,
it's supposed to be 20 minutes if they
end it.
And she goes,
why'd you guys ended so quick?
And they go,
that was 20 minutes.
She's like,
what?
And then she hit every target.
Well,
she was,
she went from being completely
ineffective to being like a fucking
world class sniper by just them jazzing
or brain up and she went into the zone
where she didn't even know she was doing
it.
So think about that.
She'd never done this before.
She sucked at it just a few minutes ago.
They put these electrodes on their head,
they give it to her and then all of a
sudden she's like,
that's interesting.
She's like a super soldier.
Is there any science today?
I mean,
is there somebody that's tested this
because why aren't we all just putting
nine volt batteries on her head?
Well,
they are testing it.
It's called,
what is the actual term?
Transdermal electrical stimulation.
Dermal cranial volt batteries at home.
Hold on a second.
What?
Say it again?
I lost the word city in a trans
transdermal cranial stimulation,
I believe.
I'm trying to.
Yeah,
I think that direct current stimulation.
That sounds right.
Yeah.
Wow.
So this is apparently,
um,
there's a lot of guys who hacked
themselves and they,
uh,
they make their own little things with
nine volt batteries and shit that you
could buy from radio shack and they just
slap a little electrodes on their head
and sap themselves sometimes kills her
sense of smell for a week.
I cook my sense of smell today,
dude,
like this is,
I'm not joking like great,
but they get benefits out of it too.
Like people were there reporting
benefits out of it,
like find a spot on the body or the
brain rather where they get it from the
outside and it makes some sort of an
impact.
When you think about your skull,
right?
Think about your skin and your skull.
If somebody shaved a part of your head
and attached some shit to the side of
your head and then shot electricity into
that area,
like your brain's going to be affected
by that.
I mean it's right there.
It's like pounded on the outside of the
brand,
but there's got to be some of it that's
going through it,
right?
He's got to be some energy that's going
through and that brain's like,
I know Kung Fu like in the matrix.
It's interesting like maybe even like
you could put like watch batteries on a
molar so there has to be like another
way to put it in your having a skullcap
that has a battery attached to it that
you can just wear everyday or something
like that.
This is exactly yet.
Go Scroll back up please.
Foot.
What is it?
Hold on.
Stop Folk Dot.
Was it doing spasm on you?
We got to get a new laptop.
Things get old folk.us.
Trans Cranial direct current stimulation
headset helps get your game on.
Wait a minute,
let me pause right here.
Speaking of game on,
I'm done filling my special,
so w,
w we gotta get a fucking land party
going on up in this bit.
Now the quake is out.
I talked to the razor people.
We're going to hook us up with some,
some gaming laptop,
putting quake.
Quake is coming.
This is a quake champions or something.
It's called.
I think it looks bad ass pcs.
You can have you seen.
Well,
they,
uh,
it's interesting,
like I told you that I was one of the
people that helped them design their
mouse in the late nineties.
Me and my friend Lou Morton,
who,
one of the writers of news radio,
who's a super smart dude and a fucking
total quake head back in the day.
He was way better than me.
He used to beat my ass.
Like I met her.
I beat his ass one time.
I was so happy.
Most of the time he fucked me up.
He's just better quake.
Quake was this crazy three d video game.
This is it right here.
This is the newest version of it.
And you play in the first person and it
is fucking.
The new ones are unbelievably cool.
Like the graphics are insane.
I gave you this sexy.
I mean,
and the end game footage of them
actually playing the game.
It's just magical.
Look at this shit.
Come on.
Why real life?
Fuck.
Real life.
Suck my Dick.
Look at this way better than real life.
You don't have any kids.
You can't pretend.
Oh,
okay.
Whoa.
See that someone shot,
oh my goodness,
Illinois.
You would be so aggressive with this
because I know you are so aggressive.
Well,
people don't know.
We haven't told them yet.
There you are.
That's how I want to be.
There was this tremendous things.
I think it's out,
man.
This is that.
This was an old game you used to play.
That is now will.
They will obviously significantly
upgraded the graphics.
I mean this is.
This is not really the game itself.
This is just the video game engine knows
the game is based on so this is similar,
so violent.
It's similar to the solid,
like in game real footage.
Watch this.
Killed,
stabbed him with a fucking chainsaw.
How about that?
How great would that be if you had that
real life?
It'd be a lot of trouble.
When does that out?
Young Jamie just announced it.
I would guess next year just announced a
set of three and this is a big
announcement.
God Damn,
that looks they're going to announce it
yet.
Oh cool.
There's that and then there's doom which
is out and that's what we're going to
have the land party plan.
Dude,
there's a new doom that's based on.
I think it's the same engine.
It's full.
So when you say you have a,
what are you saying?
You're going to have a land land.
Oh,
local area network.
Lan Party.
A local area network party is you get a
bunch of computers.
You linked them all together so that you
have zero ping so there's no latency.
What that means is like when you play a
game online,
like at least in the older games,
they're getting way better at it now and
internet speeds are way higher anyway,
but when you would press a button like
try to shoot,
there was a delay between the time that
the signal got to the server that's
hosting the game and if you were lucky
you had like a low paying like guys had
like a 30 paying or a 20 page and you're
like whoa guys got an awesome paying.
Like then it got even lower so some guys
get cable modems and shit and it got
down to like 10 and if you were local
though,
there was zero ping.
So like if we were all together and
we're playing in this room,
we would play against each other in this
crazy three d environment like this.
This is what we would see.
I missed it.
This is like a lawn parties and this is
real end game footage.
Game footage is fucking amazing.
Look at this.
This is all in game footage.
That's cool.
And then some of it's not so it's
they're mixing up but it's dope.
I played like a weird game with my
niece,
Shawna.
I don't remember what it was,
but there was four of us connected on
the I pads.
Oh yeah.
People do that to tablets and stuff,
right?
Yeah.
Well they're probably doing that with
Pokemons,
right?
Kind of.
Yeah.
I mean it's not direct direct that
person to person yet so weird.
But it was cool.
I was like,
wait,
we're all connected.
Like the idiot.
This is what they're going to do,
man.
They're going to have these things like
these video games like doom and they're
going to have those three d,
like virtual reality sets and you're
going to be playing these things out
there in the real world.
That's when people are gonna start
getting run over.
I'm going to play in the real world
for real.
Driving people around like Uber Service
for Pokemon.
Right now there's craigslist ads up
anywhere you want to go for 30 bucks.
I take Uber every day and that's one of
the greatest benefits now that because
usually you just sitting in the back of
an uber going,
God go hurry up,
you know,
but now I was just collecting pokemons
on the way to the comedy store and tell
the guy,
hey,
pull over.
I got to get a pokemon.
No,
but there was a few times where I was
like,
I almost wanted to say,
hey,
can you just go slow right here for a
second?
So as you go slow,
it would pick up the fact that you were
there.
Yeah,
it's easier.
It's easier to go.
If you're going slow,
it's easier to get things.
I thought I heard that you can't do it
over 30 miles an hour.
Like it has some sort of you you can.
No,
it doesn't work.
It's harder to do like you can't.
Like when you can't do your gps.
If you're the driver,
you can't be doing this while you're
moving.
You say you're the passenger.
Say Shut up.
Mind Your Business.
They're probably going to have to change
because I feel like a lot of people are
gonna die and get in car accidents and
there's gonna be a lot of lawsuits,
so I have a feeling in the near future
they're probably going to make it so if
it detects that you're going a certain
speed,
it's just not going to let you do
anything.
Did you get laid playing pokemon go?
Pokemon go is great for my mental
health.
I also got laid.
Oh,
pokemon got me laid.
I just got laid by telling my girl I had
to go inside or to catch a Pikachu.
Pokemon used her as a pokey ball for the
electric pokey,
Mongo Pokemongo hope Jesus Christ
pokemon.
In the beginning.
I don't know any Japanese for pocket
monster.
Monster or something,
I think it's a cartoon or something
that's a cartoon and then it became a
very successful line of video games for
kids on Nintendo and game boys and
stuff,
but it was really all just preparing
itself for this monstrous for this
moment,
but it brought it up.
I mean it was dying out so that should
have worn my pikachu outfit today.
Well,
it's obviously didn't raise the stock.
Would you say like $9 billion or
something crazy?
That nine slash 11.
I said 11 minutes.
11 stocks are just like they're going to
have all the money.
Stock in Nintendo has been hurting for a
while too,
since have xbox and playstation and this
is the exact thing they needed was this
sounds like they just made a money
printing machine.
That's insane.
I don't know where the money comes in
because it's a free game now.
You could buy things in it like that
thing that you put down on the ground
that attracts pokemon.
All those things cost money,
so just the potential,
the potential,
the connection that you're having.
If you all of a sudden created an APP
that beats twitter,
twitter's been around forever.
If you come up with something that can
be twitter like that,
you could figure out how to make money
on it.
Like my God,
snapchat,
he wanted that.
I say this but it hasn't.
Twitter had that same exact problem.
They've had a problem like monetizing
now.
Snapchat just surpassed twitter and I
think twitter is on their way out.
Honestly,
Pokey Mon could
set up.
They could set up like stops where like
you could like have places that were
places of business and you could pay to
have that stop and people have to go in
and then a certain amount of people
would just buy things there anyway,
but then you do deal with a lot of
fucking nutty people showing up your ice
cream store.
But now wait,
twitter.
I just learned how to tweet.
Welcome that.
That's it.
Like 15 years old.
I quit snap chat.
I'll try to get all of my different
possible names.
I mean snapchat is somebody snatched up.
Yeah,
it's impossible.
I don't.
I'm not really on snapchat.
I'm only on snapchat.
Filters to make to make fun.
I like that
Florida and they're so great.
People will send me some,
some great porn.
I'm not going to say who,
but this MMA fighter that he's a
comedian also.
He's just,
he,
he has a different girl every night that
he sends me like just snaps of him
fucking.
I've seen his as Dick more than I went
to,
but he sending them directly to you on
purpose.
Kinda funky directly to you is great.
Uh,
but no,
the porn is great though on there
because a lot of girls use it.
A lot of porn stars and stuff like that.
Use it like,
Hey,
if you give me so many tokens or
whatever,
you can get my snapchat.
So then they're snapshots.
They're just like full on nudity because
snapchat.
Jamie,
I don't know if this is correct,
but isn't snapchat owned by like a porn
company like pornhub or somebody famous
porn companies started snapchat because
they originally wanted to say no.
They originally wanted to have it as an
app where you can show your Dick and it
goes away in 10 seconds,
but I swear to God,
somebody told me that pornhub is the.
He just started.
It's only 26.
I don't know that he also is involved in
porn his whole life.
How dare you,
Brian got my hopes up.
Somebody told me be the.
It could be his early investors.
You're saying somebody told me this as
if you're shocked that people retarded.
Like somebody told me this person.
Well,
people get definitely get it wrong.
You know that's funny.
That's funny was whoever told me it was
very sure that I was like,
because that was probably on coke cooked
up and they were telling you the truth.
I'm telling you bro.
So fucking true.
I know my shit.
Elena,
what happened?
That pro wrestling thing you were going
out for recently?
Oh,
it was a script that just.
They haven't started casting.
Yep.
They just put out calls for two days ago
or something like that.
People probably don't even know.
It was one of the women of wrestling,
wrestling,
easy rider.
She used to crush pool balls and to
scare her enemies was hilarious.
My favorite video to make like to hit
people and then the crush the ball.
I had so much I must have like 30 balls
that day just for fun because we're the
only person that I knew before they did
pro wrestling than I went to see them do
progress.
Like I remember you came don king a
great time.
We brought a stack of people
store or from the store either.
Oh,
who'd you.
Which one did you get there?
She is talking trash.
How long did you do this for?
It was on for Tuesday.
That was Maria and Julia Ross.
He's a comic.
And Maria,
I forget her last name,
but they were easy rider for how
embarrassed.
Look at this.
What?
Oh boy.
Oh Shit.
Broke Salinas leg remember?
Yeah.
And didn't you.
Did someone break their leg
accidentally?
Selena?
No,
she didn't hurt her leg.
She muscle.
Yeah.
She pulled a muscle or something.
So she is pulling a muscle.
Yeah,
she had the brains,
the knee brace.
She had something going on.
I can't remember.
Yeah.
Well,
there was part of the story wrong.
Good Lord was our trainer and she is
amazing and so was the big lady that's
with me.
Thug.
We did this for two seasons.
It got canceled because um,
we did a paper view and what?
I can't look at that now.
Yeah.
It didn't make any money and it wasn't
just doing well,
it just wasn't doing that well in the
ratings.
But David Mclain guy,
the producer,
he's bringing it back and he's putting a
digital and I'm going to be an
announcer.
Oh really?
So obviously I'm not gonna let them
throw me around.
I could break a hip lately,
but I still love it because they trained
us to be professional stunt women,
you know?
Well it was really physical.
She hit me with a chair and I broke my
pinky.
What was the one girl that was supposed
to be like the Baywatch girl?
Oh,
there was two of them.
Like compton girls were a little racist.
Stereotypes was one girl is a god.
I can't think of her name,
her stage name,
but she basically played basketball,
slam dunk.
That was a slam dunk.
I knew it was something silly.
I mean,
while she's an,
she's an amazing athlete and uh,
she still,
I don't know if she's coming back for
this one,
but jungle girl,
Erica Porter,
she runs a gym.
She was out there.
So they're a slam dunk.
Yeah.
A John was jungle girl.
Jungle girl was one of the other
characters,
but she's,
that shit is not going to fly.
That's Bronco.
Billy Lisa.
Danielle.
She's beautiful.
She's great.
She's from Baltimore.
But then where are the uh,
summer look at that moment?
Yeah,
there was summer.
There was a bunch of different
characters.
Geez Louise,
a long time ago in the early nineties I
believe,
or late eighties,
there was a show called glow gorgeous
ladies of wrestling and that was the
same producer and they're the ones that
have a script out called glow and it's
bought.
Netflix bought it kg.
That's how raised property of the state.
What does it say?
God property of the State Prison.
These girls in orange jumpsuits.
Every one of those girls that are so
talented,
like athlete,
amazing
stunt.
They really are strong danger for two
years.
Did this.
And how many shows,
like how many shows a year would you do?
We did that.
That must be the new cast.
That must be the newer one.
Yeah.
Because there's Lonna and all the girls.
Erica porters so strong.
I love her.
AndL ,
uh,
her name was danger.
She's like a professional stump person
that does movies.
Everything.
Um,
but yeah,
so we did,
I forget how many shows,
but it was at the forum which was
amazing in Englewood.
So we were trained at the forum and we'd
be running around Johnny and Michael
Cooper would be a,
he was the coach of the sparks at the
time.
So like Lisa,
Leslie and then we'll be down there.
Did the UFC there recently?
Oh,
that's awesome.
Isn't it such a great place.
I mean it's a giant facility and it's
amazing.
And then on the walls that has all the
different people that have played there
every year,
how many times they played with my name.
Oh Shit.
We're.
No,
no,
no.
I think dices namely up there though.
Oh yeah.
I said the form.
That's right.
It was a,
it was filled with like legendary
musicians though.
When you're walking down the hall and
you like Reading Times Queen was there.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
That's a great spot.
I mean,
I was honored to be.
Yeah,
that's all from my instagram,
stevie wonder Doobie brothers,
easy rider and Alice Cooper thinks it's
crazy and that's just.
This is like Elton John Four Times in a
year coaching.
Right.
Just crazy.
David Kelly.
Oh Man.
Wild Shit.
It's just those places are so
interesting to me because uh,
like these old old venues,
they're almost like a museum as well as
being like a place where you see a show.
Yeah.
I mean so much went on in place so many.
And you could feel it.
Even being in there during the day,
like I was still honored.
I know just wrassling whatever.
But it was big deal to me,
like to be a part of that.
Well that's one of the reasons why I
think like the comedy store has to get
some sort of historic designation and
they should.
We've tried to get that.
I remember doing this should happen
because that,
that place is like historic.
It's like a museum.
I mean it really is from the pictures on
the walls to just the feel of the place
and how important that is for one
particular art form.
You know,
that place is like a fucking museum,
like a living,
breathing.
Awesome.
You can go to it right now.
Museum.
I feel like we tried to get it as a
landmark or something like that,
but it didn't work because it's too many
bodies underneath something like,
like the Chinese theater.
Like wouldn't you think that that place
it needs to stay around commands.
Chinese theater,
this right.
Considered it.
I would imagine it shouldn't be.
It has to be at.
It should try to do it before the Mitzi
passes because so it can't get torn
down.
Well that.
But that was the whole thing.
Yeah.
Like when I was her personal assistant,
we tried to get all kinds of stuff
like that because there was like they
were coming after us for different
things like not being up to date on
certain codes,
laws and things.
And then we were grandfathered in from a
lot of them and we got away with a lot
of them,
so it was like weird,
but I remember trying to get that and I
don't know if they ever followed through
with that pos to find that out,
check it out.
But they definitely showed.
You're right.
Yeah,
it obviously because it was there a long
way longer than Ciro's.
Ciro's was a hotspot in the back in the
day.
That was like where Lucille Ball Hong
and all that.
Like the main room that was.
That was a big deal to Hollywood too.
But I don't know how long that was open.
Maybe only five years,
10 years maybe.
Maybe.
But there's so many pictures of Marilyn
Monroe and all Sammy Davis junior and
Frank Sinatra.
They would play there on the weekend,
like a regular thing,
but that logic than it should have never
been allowed to become a comedy store.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm like,
I'm not sure what the etiquette is.
I probably don't remember what that part
wasn't Ciro's.
I'll have to figure that out long
enough.
It couldn't have been as nearly as long
as it was the store right now,
but when she,
she got the original roof first,
right.
And then she bought the main room later,
so when she bought the main room,
when she bought it for which she,
she loved that serious thing,
that vibe,
you know,
like the big bands and stuff like that.
So she would have buddy rich,
uh,
on the weekends at the comedy store
playing like a big his band.
And I remember like dice going,
I'm 17 years.
Oh shoot was was 17,
19,
47.
Transformed a rock and roll club in the
early because he bought it.
What was the guy that's bought it became
a comedy store and he was a DJ.
Look at that fucking neon sign.
Look how cool that is.
Yeah,
we have that.
Wow.
We have the neon sign in the basement,
the basement the other day.
That's how we do the comedy store
podcasts,
basement.
They have that thing I'm thinking of the
big round one we have in the kitchen.
The kitchen is amazing,
but she yet all that was in the basement
when she bought it from the Dj.
What was the DJC?
Mcafee was his name.
He ran the main room.
He was,
he owned that.
She bought it from him.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
So.
And that was 78 or 70?
Seventy two.
And then yeah,
around there,
like 76,
70,
76 maybe.
She bought the main room and that
became,
it was just a weird like for link 40
years of history.
Yeah,
just a few spots like that in,
in all of entertainment.
We're also many things were created or
the one area.
Yeah,
it's not like a whole lot of those spots
were important.
She wanted me to help her write a book
and I was thinking,
wow,
Mitzi wanted me to help her write a
book.
And I was like,
wow,
that would be telling me I can barely
read a book.
I'll try because I was still into the
comedy store and then she,
um,
what she really wanted to make was like
a coffee table book from um,
all the stuff in Vegas because Vegas,
she did go there in the dunes hotel for
awhile and yeah,
there were some great footage.
Pictures.
She has audio Westwood.
Westwood.
Yeah.
Westwood was a big one.
Apparently there was all before my time,
but Westwood apparently was where guys
would develop Kennison and those guys
down there they would develop at
Westwood and then they would come over
Hollywood once we'd already got their
feet under them.
Yup.
Yeah,
yeah.
Dice has a lot of stories.
Ronnie Kenny,
all those older guys I haven't talked
to,
they would always tell Westwood's
stories.
I'd be like,
what?
What do you thinking about with cool.
Here it is store west.
That's so cool.
Look at Jay Leno.
Yeah,
it looks so fresh.
Fish.
He admits were the other guys.
Good question.
I'm going to have to look.
I think billy,
uh,
so Rick Wright,
he was just on Mark Merrin's podcast.
Billy Billy West,
little skinnier guy.
I can't think of his name.
He did a cartoon again,
last name?
No,
you already asked that.
Maybe she didn't hear Robin Williams.
Oh,
he's doing golf.
He's so cute,
man.
Then of course La Jolla,
which is real similar as well.
It's a strange place that people get
sent down there.
Like other guys that are coming up.
I got lucky club with Tommy booking me
in La Jolla a lot to develop.
When I first started sending me down as
an opener and I'm just so broke.
I was like,
yeah,
I'll take you know,
exciting.
It was like 700 bucks just house for the
weekend.
You're like,
this is awesome.
And so,
uh,
yeah,
I go down a lot.
So I got like,
I fell in love with that club as a
comic.
Yeah,
condo.
Nick Apollo.
Did a comedy special there or a CD?
Well,
he was funny.
One of my favorites,
one time I was a town coordinator for a
week because Mitzi was going crazy and
like people were quitting whatever.
There was nonsense happening.
So she was like,
I need somebody in there.
So I was taking the vowels and stuff and
I noticed that Nick Depalo,
Colin the Sudanese,
live in La,
so I called him and I'm like,
Hey,
do you have any sales this week?
He goes,
I call it if I have avails,
you don't call me.
And he hung up on the ball for you and
if it doesn't my favorite comics,
I would call them and see where you at
next because I've got to close this
thing.
Right.
Let's close it up.
I am at the comedy store July Twenty
second and the 23rd and then I'm doing
July 30th with dice at the Ford
amphitheater and Kodiak Island.
Oh,
that's going to be a big one.
I'm excited to be featuring farm there
in coney island,
coney island amphitheater.
But luckily I'm excited at the 22nd
23rd.
Who you working with down there?
I'm headlining,
but I mean who you work with?
Gene Pompa was on the show and I forget
who else.
Terrible.
But I love gene Pompa London at the
comedy store.
I love it.
That's awesome.
Congratulations.
Very exciting.
All right folks,
that's it.
If you want to get a hold of eleanor and
send her pictures of your deck.
Oh yeah.
Look at the comedy store podcasts.
Listen to the comedy store podcast.
And what's your twitter again?
And instagram?
Do you got an instagram?
Same thing.
Ega Kerrigan or eleanor?
Kerrigan.
Eleanor j Dot Kerrigan.
My website and Brian Red band,
headband on twitter.
And instagram and death squad dot TV for
comedy shows.
Jonathan coming up.
Uh,
Irvine Improv tomorrow and Friday.
Icehouse t for Irvine Improv.
Awesome.
So beautiful.
So is the icehouse obviously.
Alright fuckers.
See you later.
Thank you.